So Leute moin, was ist denn jetzt für eine Keynote, ist Apple oder was?
Wann ist denn das? Wann ist denn das?
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das auch zusammen an. Jetzt? Also 19 Uhr oder was?
Los geht das Event, 19 Uhr. Leute, wir können das nicht zusammen gucken.
Also ich kann das Bild nicht einblenden. Wenn ich das Bild einblende, dann ist G-Bade.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Nee, es funktioniert nicht. Ich kann das nicht einblenden. Dann gibt es, dann gibt es
Streik. Dann müsst ihr, müsst ihr mir nebenbei erzählen, was es gerade spannendes gibt.
Wie lange geht denn das? Moment. Apple Event.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich kann das nicht zeigen. Das geht nicht.
Finanzen.net, null, alter. 19 Uhr, was? Gut, es geht wahrscheinlich eineinhalb,
zwei Stunden oder so. Ja, wie immer, wie immer. Nee, kann ich nicht gucken. Ich habe
gerade überlegt, ob ich, ob ich es mir angucken soll und ein bisschen schwätzen
dabei. Da können wir, könnten wir es zusammen gucken. Aber ich kann es nicht zeigen, ja.
Zeigt den Stream von jemand anderes. Der ist direkt streamt. Das streamt keiner
direkt. Guck, zeig es euch. Das, das, das kannst du nicht streamen. Guck, die, die
streamen alle nur sich. Also die, die labern dabei und gucken das auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm. Man, das könnte ich auch machen, aber das ist ja pepega. Guck, die
streamen alle nur sich. Die re-streamen das Event alle nicht. Aber das ist, das
ist doof. Erzählt mir mal nebenbei, was passiert.
Da muss man wahrscheinlich eh nicht wirklich zugucken. Das ist, das ist
wahrscheinlich jetzt im größten Teil. Was? Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass
der das schaut. Der, der kann den Stream genauso wenig zeigen oder hat
irgendeine Spezialgenehmigung. Ist das, ist das das Intro vom Apple Event?
Weil, weil dann ist das, dann ist das mega, mega tost. Mal gucken, was mit den
Leuten abgeht. Ich mein, vielleicht darf der das auch.
Guck, weil die streamen sich alle nicht. Also die streamen alle nicht, event, nicht,
nicht das Event, die streamen alle sich.
Und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass Lyric das streamt. Ich mein, der kann
vielleicht das Intro zeigen oder so.
Oder ist das wirklich das Intro?
Die zeigen doch kein, die zeigen doch kein, ach das ist Werbung, Keckl, das ist Ikea.
Ich wollte grad sagen, was ist, was ist mit dem, was ist mit Apple los?
Lull. Also ich kann das nicht zeigen, ich, ich, ich sehe es nicht ein. Also ich, ich
werde das auch, ich werde ja auch nichts riskieren. Bei Apple weißt du nie. Guckt,
dann hat er vielleicht irgendeine, irgendeine Spezialabmachung. Ja, können wir
uns Steve Apple angucken? Ne, Tim Apple. Ne, Steve Apple ist ja vorbei. Tim Apple. Können wir
uns angucken? Aber gut, manche restreamen anscheinend wirklich. Ich hab keine Ahnung,
wie das ist. Apple Event Restream. Also in den vergangenen Jahren waren die sehr, sehr
pingelig, was Restreaming angeht.
Das werden wir nicht machen.
Ne, ich mach das nicht, hat Apple Pech. Die haben es einmal, haben sie es mir gegeben hier
mit Strike im Stream. Ich mach das nicht mehr. Ansonsten hätten wir uns wirklich
zusammen angucken können jetzt. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das ist. Ich hab das
überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt. Das war wahrscheinlich schon wieder zwei Monate
bekannt, oder? Ich wusste es wahrscheinlich wieder als Einziger nicht.
Der Eichler, danke schön für den Sub. Okay, Chat, kommen wir mal zum heutigen Stream. Ihr
könnt ja nebenbei mir, wer Apple Zeug guckt, kann mir nebenbei erzählen, was es
spannendes gibt. Wie finden wir Apple im Stream? Das kann jede Apple finden, wie
ihr ihr wollt. Ich war mal kurz Home Assistant Upgrade in der Zwischenzeit,
wo ich euch was erzähle. Also ihr wisst ja, ich habe mir ein Fiat Elektroauto
gekauft und es gibt keine Home Assistant Integration dafür. Die haben ein
paar andere Sachen. Mein Desktop, der ist POG. POG G. Also die haben so Sachen wie
BMW zum Beispiel oder Audi haben die glaube ich auch. Ne, Puls Audi. Also die
haben ein paar, die guckt hier, die haben ein paar Audio Integrations hier. Reno haben sie. Also wenn
ich hier irgendwie so ein Baguette Auto hätte, dann würde das funktionieren. Oder
China-Chinesen-Autos oder so Zeug. Also nicht so viele. Aber ein paar offizielle
Integrations haben die. Mach mal kurz die Dark-Dings raus. Flashbang. Also ein paar offizielle
Integrations haben die für Autos, aber kein Fiat dabei. Wobei Fiat ja auch nicht
wirklich Fiat ist, sondern das ist Fiat G Giddens. Das sind mehr, das ist nicht nur
Fiat. So, deswegen habe ich mich mal schlau gemacht. Wie gesagt, ich mach mal kurz Home Assistant Upgrade in der Zwischenzeit.
Ich habe mich mal schlau gemacht und zwar, wie macht das die App? Also sprich, es gibt von Fiat,
da müssen wir uns gleich einen Fake Account anlegen, um das ganze mal auszuprobieren. Login. Also Fiat hat
einen Web Service und eine App. Und ich habe heute Mittag mal ein bisschen mitgeschnitten, was die so
machen. Und ich muss sagen, es sieht machbar aus, dass sich den ihre API quasi zu zweck empfremden.
Wir machen uns jetzt einen Fake Account ohne Auto drinne, weil ich log mich hier bestimmt nicht mit
meinen echten Credentials ein und ihr könnt dann mein Auto fernsteuern oder sowas. Das werden wir
hier nicht machen. Also ich habe aber eine Response mitgeschnitten bei mir im Browser. Die habe ich
anonymisiert. Die habe ich mir hier schon als JSON Datei hinkopiert. Das heißt, wir können die
Home Assistant Integration testen. Aber erstmal gucken wir, wie man den Kram Batterie auslesen.
Also was du machen kannst, ist, nur mal so zum erklären, warum man das dann machen will. Also,
du kannst, Moment, ich mache mal kurz die JSON Datei auf, dann kann ich es euch zeigen. Die Datei
heißt keckel.json, da wissen wir schon Bescheid. Also, du kannst so Sachen auslesen, wie zum
Beispiel Kilometerzähler. Kilometerstand kannst du auslesen. Du kannst, bisschen laut, oder? Passt
eigentlich. Du kannst den Kilometerstand auslesen. Du kannst auslesen, wie viel Reichweite noch in
der Batterie drinne ist, wie viel du noch aktuell fahren kannst. Du kannst Reifendruck auslesen,
für jeden Reifen einzeln. Da kannst du dann quasi in deinem Dashboard, kannst du dann quasi sowas
hier machen, mit einem Auto in der Mitte. Und dann kannst du dann quasi anzeigen, hier, der ist
kaputt und die hier sind alle grün und sowas. Also Reifendruck kannst du auslesen, für jedes
Rad einzeln. Batterieinfo kannst du auslesen und zwar, nee, Moment, das kommt später. Du kannst
die, du kannst die letzten, den letzten Trip, also das letzte, was du gefahren bist, auslesen. Dann
hast du quasi Automation History, an welchem Tag du wie viel gefahren bist. Dann kannst du auslesen,
weil ich, warum, ich copypaste einfach das Jason rüber und zeig's euch, dann seht ihr's. Moment,
Original Format hier. Gehen wir mal hier rüber, Visual Studio Code auf. Müssen wir jetzt eh
einen Fake Account machen. Wir müssen, ich erzähl euch gleich, was wir machen. Verschiedene,
verschiedene Sachen. Also hier, so, hier haben wir mal das, anonymisiert Jason von meinem Auto
aus dem Browser. Also, du siehst zum Beispiel, wie gesagt, Kilometerzähler, das sind nicht 35.000,
wie gesagt, anonymisiert, was ich im Browser mitgeschnitten hab von meinem Auto. So, dann
siehst du, wie lange du noch fahren kannst, bis die Batterie leer ist. Äh, gut, Ölstand gibt's da
natürlich nicht drin. Dann hast du Reifendruck, da siehst du vorne links, vorne rechts. Äh, nee.
Rear, Rear ist das, oder? Rear Right, Rear Left, Front, Front Right, Front Left. Also,
vorne links, vorne rechts, hinten links, hinten rechts. Also, siehst du den Reifendruck,
beziehungsweise du siehst, ob der Reifendruck okay ist. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was sich in der
Regel interessiert. Äh, Spannung von der Batterie. Dann kannst du dir den letzten Trip anzeigen lassen,
der hat zwei Zähler drinne, der sich immer resetet. Also, du kannst zum Beispiel automatische Statistik
erstellen, an welchem Tag du wie viel gefahren bist. Beispielsweise heute, 45 Kilometer. Also,
hier um die Ecke. Dann siehst du, wie lange du brauchst, bis du wieder in die Werkstatt fahren
musst. Dann siehst du, wie viele Räder du dran hast. Für den Fall der Fälle, dass du das nicht
weißt. Ich frag mich allen Ernstes, ob diese Api was... Die haben doch bestimmt Hardcoded 4,
oder? Das ist doch Return 4. Die haben doch nicht wirklich einen Sensor, der ausliest,
wie viele Räder da dran sind. Das ist Return 4, Hardcoded bei denen auf der Seite. Um an diese
Api zu kommen, ist das Problem. Das ist keine offizielle Api. Da musste erst 50 Authentifizierungs-
sachen durchmachen. Ich habe es nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Dann kannst du irgendwie Klimaanlage, Power Usage, blablabla, was sonst noch alles, keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt kommen ein paar interessante Sachen für Leute, die ein Elektroauto haben. Der Rest ist
ja mehr oder weniger auch für andere verfügbar. Du kannst Charging Schedules einstellen, was
wahrscheinlich kein Mensch benutzt. Aber hier siehst du zum Beispiel, der Batterie ist aktuell bei
98%. Er ist angeschlossen... Also es gibt Level 1 Charging und Level 2 Charging. Level 1 Charging
ist Kona Charging. 120 Volt. Hell yeah. Also bei uns in Deutschland wirst du eigentlich nur Level
2 Charging an der Stelle sehen. Also er ist angeschlossen an 230 Volt. Plugin Status True,
also sprich der Stecker ist drin. Minuten sind das hier. Minuten bis voll geladen. Also irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, das ergibt keinen Sinn wie gesagt. Ich habe die Werte ein bisschen anonymisiert. Also
sprich der braucht irgendwie noch 10 Stunden oder so bis er voll geladen ist. Er ist aktuell am
Laden. Total Range mit dieser Ladung 290 Kilometer und insgesamt 320 Kilometer.
Gut, das hier braucht kein Mensch. Das war's. Also sowas kann man da abfragen. Excellent. So,
die Sache ist bloß ein bisschen problematischer, erstmal an die Infos zu kommen. Also ich habe mir
einmal diese Sachen aus dem Browser gezogen, dass wir heute Home Assistant Integration machen
kann. Aber ich muss erstmal das Login auf die Reihe kriegen. Und das Login sieht wirklich
extremst pepega aus. Da müssen wir uns gleich mal einen Fiat Fake Account erstellen und versuchen,
ob ich das Login hin bekomme. Wie gesagt, das ist richtig pepega. Also ich habe mir das angeguckt.
Ich habe einen IO Broker Projekt gefunden, wo man abgucken kann und ich habe EVCC oder so heißt das
glaube ich gefunden. Das ist für Leute, die Solarpanels haben. Da kann man auch mal spicken
in der API, wie die das gemacht haben. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der Teil hier ist. Fiat,
irgendwas Fiat. Ja. AP. Ja, hier. Ja, so Sachen stehen da drin. Die AP Keys, die haben die irgendwie
aus der, aus der, ich wette mit euch die AP Keys haben sie aus der Android App. Die haben die Android
App sich, die haben sich das APK geholt von der Android App, haben das dekompiliert und haben
sich die AP Keys rausgeholt. Könnte ich wetten, dass es daher kommt. Ist die Musik zu laut oder
passt das so? So und das Einloggen müssen wir halt ausprobieren. Also es gibt, es gibt quasi zwei
Sachen. Warum habe ich hier so viel Zeug drauf? Also es gibt, es gibt zwei, mehrere Sachen, die
wir machen. Erstes, wie geht das Login? Geil. Wie geht das Login auf, auf der Fiat Seite? Per API
natürlich, nicht per Browser. Also was ich sehr ungern machen würde, ist einen Browser
fernsteuern. Also irgendwie Puppetier oder so und einen Browser oder Selenium oder so was und einen
Browser fernsteuern. Da bin ich nicht scharf drauf. Das muss schon irgendwie über diese API von denen
gehen und man kann sich das hier auch abgucken, dass das, das funktioniert halbwegs. Ich zeige
euch gleich mal grob, wie das funktioniert. Ich habe mir das vorhin schon angeguckt. Richtig pepeger
Authentifizierungsprozess, aber hardcore. So und danach brauchen wir MQTT, HA-Integration und ja
1.5 ist dann vier Zeug zu JSON umwandeln für Home Assistant. So in der Richtung. Wir probieren
jetzt erstmal das Login hinzukriegen und wenn das Login funktioniert, weil wie gesagt, ich kann es
halt nicht mit meinen echten Daten machen, sonst liege ich hier irgendwelche Session Talks und
ihr schließt mein Auto auf oder so. Serious Max, das ist ziemlich kacke. Also nicht von dir,
aber dass es geht. So alles klar. Na ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube viele machen es halt auch,
weil machen das ja nicht absichtlich, die merken es einfach nicht. Auf YouTube lade ich das nicht,
das kann man sich als Wort angucken. Ich habe doch hier ein Archiv, da kann man noch alles nachgucken.
Ich lade das eh auf GitHub hoch, wenn es denn dann wirklich funktionieren sollte. LTE, beides,
beides. Kannst beides machen. Der hat LTE drinne, das ist aber nur für drei Jahre inklusive,
aber du kannst auch WLAN machen. Aber ich habe das ehrlich gesagt mit WLAN noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also ich habe den Dialog schon gesehen, um ihn mit WLAN zu verbinden, aber ich mache das bisher
alles über LTE. Wenn das drei Jahre inklusive ist, werde ich das erstmal ausnutzen. Ach die,
ach ich habe sie übrigens letztens installiert noch auf Stream. Guck mal hier vorbildlich wieder,
vorbildlich unser Mod. Wollte ich gar nicht machen, das hier. Vorbildlich. Die Musik ist
mir zu anstrengend gerade. Leute, ich brauche, ich brauche Massive, ja Relaxing. Exzellent.
Ulz sind zu. Was? Ulz sind zu übersichtlich und kurz. Exzellent Ulz. Du kannst aber auch
Emoji Ulz machen. Gleich Massive Relaxing mehr jetzt die Musik hier. So alles klar.
Nein ich will nicht den Mailcheck Champ aufmachen. Ich will erstmal ein neues Projekt anlegen,
weil wir gerade schon dabei sind. Repos, New, ne MK Dear, wie nennen wir das Ding? Pia Champ.
So New, Console. Okay, also achso ja ich habe noch eine Sache vergessen, die ich noch nie
gemacht habe. Wir machen daraus eine Docker Home Assistant Addon. Habe ich noch nie gemacht,
dann kann man das direkt über den Home Assistant App Store installieren. Das wollen wir nicht
alles heute machen, das kann ich euch gleich schon sagen. Wahrscheinlich wird mich der Login schon
übelst abfacken, aber irgendwann muss man mal anfangen. Und in dem Fall habe ich tatsächlich
auch ein gewisses eigenes Interesse daran das fertigzustellen, weil ich brauche das selbst
für mein Auto. Für Haxe, ne nicht für Haxe. Haxe sind ja nur Python Integrations, Docker,
die Docker Integrations, also sprich ich wollte Home Assistant Update machen, fällt mir nicht
gerade auf. Muss ich mal machen, 2, 1, was? 1, 3, 2. Das ist Zappix. 8, 1, 2, 3. Qta, alles klar. Also so war es hier, guck. Addons. So einen Addon gibt
das dann. Kannst du dafür dann Fiat installieren. Was hast du alles in meinem Smartphone drin?
Du kannst mal bei mir auf... Du kannst mal bei mir auf... Ist es schlimm, dass Safe Search
deaktiviert ist? Die Ergebnisse können nackt, teigt, sexuell, inhalt und anstößige Safe
Search Einstellungen verwalten. 1, ok. Wir wollen hier keinen Gatschi-Buzz haben. Hier,
du kannst mal bei mir auf YouTube gucken im Video. Ich zeige ein bisschen was, wobei,
wie gesagt, ich zeige nicht alles und mittlerweile ist natürlich wie immer noch ein bisschen
mehr drin, ein paar Sachen sind weggekommen, aber du kannst hier so mal grob gucken, so
ein paar Sachen zeige ich hier im Video. Wobei, so viel zeige ich gar nicht. So und dann gibt
es noch das Video. Dann gibt es noch das da. Was ist auf meinem Home Server? Da zeige
ich auch... Guck, hier zeige ich meinen Home Assistant. Da, das kannst du gucken. Aber
wie gesagt auch nicht alles. Nur so ein paar Sachen. Genau, wir müssen mal kurz nebenbei
updaten Home Assistant Core installen. Jawoll, gib ihm. Ok, also wir machen uns jetzt mal
ein Fiat-Fake-Account. 10-Minute-Mail. Mal gucken, ob die 10-Minute-Mail überhaupt zulassen.
Perfekt. Fiat-Uconnect-Login. Einmal Fake-Account-Blitz. Das muss ich wegmachen, die Seite ist zu
langsam mit Dark Reader. Äh, registrieren. Ich mach den Account danach auch wieder weg.
So, Deutschland. Vorname, Keck. L. E-Mail. Wie? Der Nachname darf nur Buchstaben enthalten,
muss mindestens zwei Zeichen lang sein. So, perfekt. So heißen, so glaub normale Leute
können schon mal so heißen. So, Passwort. Passwort, muss ich mal kurz eins ausdenken.
Ok. Nein, nein, das da nicht. Oh man, ich hab zu viel... Alter, jetzt sind auch noch
die Zeichen zu lang. Ich fass es nicht. 1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11. Das ist
ja nix. Ok, dann machen wir jetzt nochmal neu. Oh man, geht man nicht auf den Sack. Wo ist
denn das Problem? Mein Passwort ist zu lang. Ok, jetzt aber. Ich hoffe jetzt passt das.
Ich finde die Längenbegrenzung ist so unsinnig. Ich mein, ok, man könnte sagen 60 Stellen
sind vielleicht ein bisschen lang, aber ansonsten, ich mein, warum nicht? Nein, nein, nein, nein,
wir lehnen alles ab, alles ab. Alter. Ok, zum Dashboard wechseln. Jetzt kriege ich...
Ja, speichern wir mal, vergesse ich eh. Äh, gucken wir uns mal die Bestätigungs-E-Mail
an. Konto verifizieren. Excellent. Ihr Konto aktivieren. Accept. Konto ist activated. Leute,
Konto activated. Oder auch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht braucht das einfach ein bisschen,
bis das Konto activated ist. So, und jetzt passt mal auf. Diese Login-Geschichten sind
wirklich extrem... Ich dachte schon, ich bin gerade mit meinem Account drin, weil da der
500 da drin steht. So, also dieses Login müssen wir jetzt nachbauen. Und ich sage euch, Leute,
das wird abartig. Ähm, kurz nochmal öffnen. Was ist denn mit meinem Rider los? Sag mal,
was fehlt? Ich wollte gerade sagen, da fehlt doch was. Wir müssen das nachbauen. Naja,
wie willst du dich sonst einloggen, wenn du das Login nicht nachbaust? Kannst du dich
nicht einloggen? Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist Browser fernsteuern und hoffen,
dass alles funktioniert. Aber das will ich nicht. Ich will kein Browser fernsteuern.
Nee, hab ich keinen Bock drauf. Machen wir das jetzt so. Okay, und zwar wir können uns
das hier abgucken. Leute, es ist richtig, es ist hardcore eklig, diese Authentifizierung
barfiert. Also ich zeige euch mal, ich hab's mir im Vorfeld ja schon angeguckt. Also guckt
mal was, also erst mal, haben die zig verschiedene Wurls? Also, okay, ich versuch's euch mal
so grob zu erklären, wie ich das verstanden hab. Also, es gibt die Fiat API, es gibt das
Fiat Authentifizierungsportal, es gibt AWS Authentifizierung und es gibt dann am Ende
ein Fiat Access Token, mit dem man die API benutzen kann. Also das ist wirklich ganz,
ganz grausam. So, ich versuch euch das mal kurz hier zu zeigen in diesem Beispiel. Oder
wir können es auch in dem JavaScript Beispiel, ich zeig's euch mal in dem Go Beispiel, ich
finde das ist ein bisschen schöner zu sehen. Also, wo ist hier der Login? Login, okay,
also es fängt schon mal folgendermaßen an. Als erstes muss man einen Request machen hier
auf die fiat url slash accounts web sdk bootstrap. Allein schon das sollte irgendwie einen kleinen
Hinweis darauf geben, dass das nicht die offizielle API ist, die dafür gedacht ist, dass die jeder
verwendet. So, dann muss man hier einen Webrequest machen und diese komischen magic Parameter
angeben, dass es funktioniert. Mit dem API Key, den sie wahrscheinlich aus der Android
App extrahiert haben oder so, keine Ahnung, ich klau mir den hier einfach. So, dann muss
man hier noch Zeug angeben, dann bekommt man hier als Antwort von dem Request irgendwelche
JSON Objekte. Wenn man dann die Antwort hiervon hat, kann man einen weiteren Request machen
auf Accounts login, da muss man dann noch mehr Zeug übergeben, da muss man dann unter anderem
auch, also der erste Request ist nur dazu da, soweit ich das verstanden hab, die Cookies
zu holen. Also man muss diesen ersten Request nur machen, dass die Cookies initial gefüllt
werden, dass man initial paar Cookies bekommt, dass es dann weiter geht danach. Danach macht
man den nächsten Request und diesmal mit Login ID, Passwort, API Key, Java, Gedöns, irgendwelche
Include, Profile, Data, E-Mails, keine Ahnung, User Info, brauchen wir alles nicht, Login
Mode, Standard, Language, DE0DE, Mindblown, kein Schimmer. So und wenn das dann durch
ist, dann bekommt man eine ID und diese ID braucht man, das ist die Unique ID für deinen
User, mit dem du dich eingeloggt hast, weiterhin ist wichtig, dass du alle Cookies in deinem
Cookie Top speicherst, dass es weiter geht danach. Wenn du diesen Request gemacht hast,
also das ist in der Theorie, ich hab's ja noch nicht ausprobiert, theoretisch funktioniert
das so, so wenn du das gemacht hast, dann machst du einen weiteren Request, das ist wirklich
die komplizierteste Authentifizierung, die ich je gesehen hab im Leben. Danach machst
du einen weiteren Request um einen JSON Web Token zu erhalten und dann brauchst du deine
angeforderten Credentials eingeben, einstellen die du haben willst, wieder den API Key übergeben
und immer schön die Cookies verwenden, immer schön die Cookies verwenden vom letzten Request,
so und dann bekommt man hier irgendwann ein Objekt zurück, in diesem Objekt ist ein Token
und eine Identity ID und dieses Token, wenn ihr, Moment, chat, wenn ihr denkt, wir sind
jetzt fertig, jetzt geht's erst richtig los, jetzt geht's erst richtig los mit dem Logging,
weil jetzt kommt noch, jetzt kommt noch AWS, jetzt kommt noch AWS Request zu Amazon gleich,
also danach bekommt man ein Token und eine Identity ID und die braucht man dann wiederum,
um einen Request zu machen zu Amazon, nämlich, das ist ein Amazon AWS Cognito Identity Service
Request, den wir jetzt machen muss, dazu braucht man das Token und die Ident ID, die man bekommen
hat und dann kann man zu AWS gehen und sich dort dann ein Token abholen, mit dem man,
wenn man das dann hat, in Verbindung mit der ID von ganz hier oben auf die rechtlichen APIs
zugreifen kann, ich weiß nicht genau, wer sich das ausgetacht hat, bei Fiat, aber so
ist es anscheinend und das müssen wir jetzt versuchen, irgendwie nachzubauen, ach ja,
zwischendurch müssen wir auch irgendwelche AWS Request, jetzt ist mir die Musik doch
ein bisschen zu Relaxing, haben wir nicht noch, haben wir noch irgendwie Top Mario Songs haben
wir doch hier immer, ja genau, exzellent, wir müssen nicht C und C Sharp Go Interop machen,
wir bauen das, wir bauen das in C Sharp nach, ich habe AWS in.NET noch nie verwendet,
wobei das stimmt nicht, doch habe ich, aber nie wirklich um was damit zu bauen und wie
das hier funktioniert, hat schon jemand mal AWS Request gesigned mit.NET, ich weiß noch
nicht mal, was das überhaupt bedeutet, also ich bin gespannt, ob wir dieses Login hinbekommen,
wir können sowohl hier abgucken, wie das funktioniert, wir können aber auch hier abgucken,
wie das funktioniert, also wir haben hier zwei Alternativen, wenn es nicht funktioniert,
können wir es uns abgucken, einmal in dem IO Broker Plugin oder einmal hier drinnen,
ok auf geht's, also wir Copy Paste uns erstmal die ganzen AP Keys, weil die brauchen wir
auf jeden Fall, erstmal AP Keys abrippen und die Connect World brauchen wir garantiert
auch, so War AP Key, Login AP Key, ok den gibt es anscheinend auch, ja 4 Uhr, also Leute
ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das was wird, ich bin wirklich schon happy, wenn ich das hier
schaffe nach dieser Schatzsuche mich einzuloggen, LEAKED, OMFG Alter, OMFG, LEAKED,
ich bin gerade am überlegen, wie wir das am besten machen, wir machen das mal, wir machen
das schonmal richtig 6 Head Object Orientated, jetzt hier, Class, Fiat, Client oder so, bisschen
laut, die Musik passt wieder exzellent dazu, ok Fiat Client, also was brauchen wir, wir
brauchen auf jeden Fall, ich kann ja mal schreiben, wir brauchen ein String, User, String, Passwort,
das ist schon mal relativ klar, User Name und Passwort, so und dann brauchen wir so
wie Public, Public Key, Alter, ich kann heute nicht schreiben, Public, was ist, sag mal Public,
was genau möchtest du in deinem Home Assistant integrieren, integriert mein Auto, ich will
beispielsweise meinen Kilometerzähler sehen, meinen Reifendruck sehen, wie voll die Batterie
geladen ist und sowas und es gibt für Fiat keine Integration, deswegen baue ich jetzt
für Fiat eine Integration, beziehungsweise für Fiat, das geht Fiat und Jeep und alles
was Uconnect verwendet, geht dann hoffentlich, ich kann es halt nur mit meinem Auto ausprobieren,
ok Login, sag mal, ok, Void, Login, wir brauchen ein HTTP Client, also auf jeden Fall SYNC,
und auch Task, so, also wie machen wir jetzt das Login, jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds spannend,
also New Fiat Client, ja Passwort und User, muss ich mal gucken wo ich das verstecke gleich,
dass ihr das nicht seht, weil auch wenn das ein Fake Ding ist, ich will es trotzdem nicht
im Klartext reinschreiben, kann man, kann man eigentlich den Fiat Account wieder löschen,
so doof gefragt, kann man in meinem Profil, meint ihr, meint ihr man kann den Account
wieder löschen, wahrscheinlich nicht oder, das ist nicht im Scope, dass man den Account
wieder löscht, ne, den Account kann man nicht wieder löschen, man kann sich bei 3000 Social
Media Sachen anmelden, aber den Account löschen ist nicht, ist nicht vorgesehen, Account löschen
gibt es nicht, sonst hätte ich den Account halt direkt danach wieder gelöscht, aber
vielleicht löschen ist ja automatisch wenn man die E-Mail nicht, war der Account deaktivieren
echt, wo, ne, ne, deaktivieren, ach hier unten, Alter ist das versteckt, MonkaS, das
ist echt, ich mein ernsthaft, what the fuck, Alter wie versteckt ist das, ne kann ich
doch nicht, vielleicht, vielleicht nach dem Stream, so, also schauen wir uns mal, wie
können wir uns jetzt einloggen, also fangen wir mal an, das erste was wir machen müssen
für den Login ist ein Request hier rauf, ich copy paste mir das jetzt einfach mal,
ich copy paste mir das jetzt mal hier hin und dann gucken wir mal wie wir das hier nachgebaut
bekommen, das da will ich copy paste, so, wie wir das hier nachgebaut bekommen, ich
will es nicht eins zu eins nachbauen, ich will bloß wissen wie es funktioniert, also,
dann installieren wir mal einen ordentlichen Webclient, ok, fiatclient login, await, tackle,
das ist erstmal egal, weil noch, ich will auch mal die Fehlermeldung sehen, ach ne, Moment,
da oben, muss ich das hier eingeben, Username, Passwort, so, also, fiatclient login, alles
klar, so, wie funktioniert das jetzt, wir brauchen wahrscheinlich, welche URL brauchen
wir denn jetzt zum Login, login-URL-URI, login-URI ist das da, ok, login-URL, ok, aber
das weg, das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich nicht und das muss auch in die Klasse rein, einfach
eine böse DSGVO-Mail schreiben, ja, auf italienisch, wenn schon dann richtig, private, dring, api-key,
also, ok, also, login-URL, append, nee, path, nee, add, nee, wie ging das nochmal, was mit
pass, append-path-segment ist es genau, accounts-bootstrap, dann brauchen wir cookies, cookies, cookies,
nochmal müssen wir uns speichern, es gibt jetzt eine Apple Watch Ultra, na geil, use cookies,
cookies, irgendwas mit cookies, und was ist an der so viel geiler, die ist jetzt mega
fett oder wie, das ist gut, chat, das ist doch optimal, guck mal, wir können hier ein
bisschen basteln und nebenbei kriegen wir sogar noch die News aus dem Apple Stream mit,
ok, also, sehe ich das soweit richtig, also, account, dahin müssen wir ein Request machen
mit, dass wir uns die Cookies speichern, dann müssen wir glaube ich den api-key noch setzen,
ok, set, parameters, api-key, nee, wie wird da geschrieben, ich traue diesem Go Zeug immer
nicht, weil Go serialisiert das Chasen und unter der Haube sieht es dann anders aus,
wo ist denn hier das login, login, ach du scheiße, javascript please, login, api-key,
guck so muss man es nämlich schreiben, api-key, wir brauchen auch nicht diesen api-key, wir
brauchen den login api-key, ok, api-key, login api-key, na mal gucken ob das was wird, jetzt
bin ich echt gespannt, so, haben wir das jetzt alles, ok, da muss man diesen Crap da unten
dran schreiben, wir probieren mal ob es ohne geht, wir gucken mal ob es ohne geht, mal schauen
was da jetzt als Request zurückkommt, ich bin mal, ich bin gespannt, was da jetzt raus
kommt, ok, machen wir eben keine Ahnung, login-response, get-string, so, schauen wir mal was da als Antwort
kommt, bin mal gespannt, run, schauen wir mal, ja auf, ah, ich hab es nicht erwartet, mal
gucken was da als Antwort jetzt kommt, ey guck mal, da kommt sogar was, status ok, wie
das jetzt einfach funktioniert oder was, da hätt ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht mit gerechnet,
aber wir machen jetzt sixhead-time, guck mal, quicktype, io, wir lassen uns daraus jetzt
in.net-typ generieren, fivehead, bam, so, da bis jetzt funktioniert es, so machen wir
mal hier eine neue Klasse für dieses Fiat, Fiat-Gedöns, Fiat-RP-Response, nennen wir
das einfach mal als Base oder so, ja wunderbar, also dann können wir jetzt auch sagen get,
Jason Async, Fiat-RP-Response und dann kann ich hier auch drauf zugreifen, ja, nice, wie
gut ist der Browser Vivaldi, ich finde ihn eigentlich ganz nice, aber ich verwende ihn
selten, klingt jetzt zwar merkwürdig, aber tja, so ist es halt, so und was ist mit diesem
ganzen Krämpel hier, SDK, GS Latest und sowas, braucht man das, ich habe einen Fiat 500e gekauft,
der steht bei mir im Hof gerade und jetzt will ich ihn meinem Home Assistant einbieten,
dass ich dann so Sachen sehe wie Reifendruck, wie viel es geladen ist, ist er gerade eingesteckt,
ist er gerade am laden, mach mal lieber Format gleich Jason, sonst kommt noch XML zurück,
du hast recht, ja, Set, Query-Parameter, Params, kann man glaube ich noch mehr machen, New,
SDK, GS Latest, ich setze diesen ganzen Krämpel hier mal, man weiß ja nie, vielleicht, nicht
dass es da nachher nicht geht, man weiß ja, es hat bestimmt seinen Grund warum die das
mitgeben, nur das mit dieser Page, ich glaube das mit dieser Page kann man sich echt sparen,
so, wo ist denn meine Dump Methode, die brauche ich hier, ich kann mir die auch aus einem
anderen Projekt kopieren, wichtigste, wichtigstes Ding was ich überall brauche, wo ist meine
Helper, Helper Class, wo ist es, ich muss gerade auf den zweiten Bildschirm gucken,
hier, exellent, komisch, ja, man hat immer noch solche Dinge, wie Hedda, tja, musste
Fiat fragen, Public, was will der immer mit Public Key, Public, Static, Pipehead Helper
Class, die brauche ich, die brauche ich immer, so, wisst ihr was man mit der machen kann,
da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, Login Response, Dump, und dann gibt es mit dem Debug Modus
aus, Bäm, zack, und wenn der Reifentuch nicht stimmt, kann man sich dann da mit einem 3D
Drucker eine Sirene ausdrucken, naja, du kannst zumindest das in deinem Dashboard anzeigen
lassen, dass du siehst, dass der Reifentruck nicht stimmt, du kannst theoretisch sogar
Hupen über die API glaube ich, ich glaube man kann Hupen über die API, also falls irgendjemand
seine Nachbarn wirklich abfacken will, kann er Hupen automatisieren über sein Home Assistant,
was ich nicht empfehlen würde, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass er sogar illegal ist,
zu sehr Lärmbelästigung durch Hupen, durch unsinniges, also Hupen verwenden ohne dass
man Hupen braucht.
Ja, so ungefähr, so also, das erste hat ja schonmal funktioniert, ich hab ne Idee, Leute,
ich hab ne Idee, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das ne gute Idee ist, wir könnten sowas
machen wie hier, war, default, paar rams oder sowas, new, dictionary, string, irgendwie
sowas, und, oh nee, wie ist die, wie ist die Syntax dafür, so oder, die ist ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig, so, nee, äh, Moment, wie ist denn die richtige Syntax dafür jetzt,
ich, doch, ist doch richtig, oder, nee, da ist ne Klammer zu viel, nee, oh nee, wie funktioniert
das nochmal, ähm, ach, da fehlt, da fehlt ein Quote, deswegen geht das nicht, ja, na,
okay, jetzt ergibt das, ergibt das tatsächlich, so, ähm, ja, genau, das da, so, SDK, Format,
so, dann können wir nämlich den Campbell wahrscheinlich einfach defaultmäßig übergeben, hier plus,
also quasi das da, und dann einfach plus die defaultparameter, wenn wir die mal wieder
brauchen, ich gehe davon aus, wir brauchen die noch öfters gleich, alles klar, okay,
geht noch alles, check check, okay, gut, irgendwo musste man auch Session Timeout angeben, wo
gibt man denn Session Timeout an, wo war das denn, Session Timeout, hier, beim nächsten,
beim nächsten, Session Expiration, weil da, da geben wir nur ne Minute an oder so, selbst
wenn ich Session Tokens liege, so schnell hat das keiner abgetippt, also, hier, so, den
ersten Schritt haben wir hinbekommen, wunderbar, der nächste, der nächste Request, also, Cookies,
Cookies setzen haben wir hinbekommen, wir können, wir können, nee, wobei ich gebe
die Cookies nicht aus, wer weiß was man damit anstellen kann, also ich mein, mehr als den
Account hier übernehmen kann man eh nicht, und den Account lösche ich danach, aber man
muss es ja nicht übertreiben, so, nächster Request, was braucht man als nächstes, hier
bekommen wir jetzt unsere UID, okay, also, ach du Scheiße, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen
mehr, was man hier setzen muss, ah, wir können gucken, und ich hab ne Idee, wir können gucken,
ob die, ob die Response okay ist, also quasi, if Login Response Status Code und gleich
200, ähm, keine Ahnung, Login failed oder so, irgendwie, oder wir können, oder wir können
richtig, richtig Sixhead ob Object Oriented tuttet sein, und, und machen so was wie, äh,
Public Void Throw on Error, String Message, if, wahrscheinlich ist das, der einzige, das
einzige Mal, wo ich diese Klasse hier brauche, und danach sind es immer andere Antworten,
if und gleich 200, New Network Exception oder sowas, ach, keine Ahnung, einfach, Base Exception,
fällt grad nicht ein, welche Message, irgendwie so, und dann können wir noch hinten dran
die Status Codes hängen, Error, Error, Error ist übrigens richtig cringe, ja, HiSJohi,
Dankeschön für den Sub, man könnte, man könnte tatsächlich noch jetzt sowas hinten
dran hängen wie Status, Status Code oder so, aber scheiß drauf, komm Error Handling, Kackel
Alter, wer braucht denn sowas, geh, geh, gehste, gehste fort hier, weg, weg damit, weg, zwar
zumindest können wir jetzt eine Sache machen, was es ein bisschen, ein bisschen hübscher,
ein bisschen hübscher macht, Login, Response, ja, ich mein, das sieht, das sieht ein bisschen
schicker aus, ja, dann ist das hier abgehakt, es ist auch so, guter Code hat keine Errors,
ja, das ist richtig, allerdings ist die Fiat API wahrscheinlich kein guter Code, deswegen
hat die manchmal Errors, gerade was Connection angeht, und Vodafone auch, aber jetzt machen
wir mal weiter, also wir haben jetzt unsere Cookies gesetzt, alles gut, jetzt brauchen
wir wieder ein Request, wahrscheinlich auf die Login-Uhr, ja, Login, Login-Uhr, so und
diesmal, diesmal brauchen wir aber Accounts Login, und dann testen wir jetzt auch gleich
mal, ob das Login nicht funktioniert, neuer Job, ne, warum, war immer noch das gleiche
wie vorher, so Accounts Login, so was brauchen, ist das jetzt ein Postrequest oder was machen,
was machen die denn, hier ist das ein Post, ah, das ist jetzt ein Postrequest, aha, das
ist jetzt ein Postrequest, wo das da alles in den Body rein muss, ne, die können sich
auch nicht entscheiden, oder, bei Fiat, was das jetzt werden soll, also Login, ok, wir
müssen jetzt ein Request machen auf Accounts Login, und dann wird das, also mit unseren
Cookies natürlich, ohne Cookies geht hier nichts, Query-Parameters und sowas brauchen
wir alles nicht, ne, Post, Post, Jason Essink, also wir wollen ein Jason-Objekt schicken,
und zwar, aber jetzt muss ich wirklich diesen ganzen Crap da rein schreiben, wait, was ist
das jetzt, Aus-Response, ok, Receive, Receive-String, und dann gucken wir mal, ob da was Sinnvolles
rauskommt, was passiert denn, wenn ich ein Post mache, einfach so, da sollte jetzt irgendein
Error zurückkommen, ja, guck mal, Missing, Missing Required-Parameter, AP-Key, ja gut,
ist doch in Ordnung, also was brauchen wir da jetzt, brauchen wir, Moment, diesen Krempel
von da oben geben die hier wieder an, also will ich jetzt wahrscheinlich sowas machen
wie Default, Params, Concat oder so, gibt es sowas, oh je, das wird jetzt aber eklig,
sicher, dass man das so machen will, ne, oder, ne, ne, ich glaube nicht, dass wir das so machen
wollen, ne, ne, das funktioniert so, glaubt eher nicht, dann muss ich mir mit den Default-Parametern
doch irgendwas überlegen, ach, Moment, ich mache es ja auch falsch, das kommt ja auch
nicht da rein, das muss ja auch direkt hier hin, guck mal, das funktioniert, ok, das sieht
zwar nicht hübsch aus, aber, ich meine, könnte, könnte schlimmer sein, so, also, was brauchen
wir da jetzt für Parameter, Login-ID brauchen wir, wir brauchen einiges, wir brauchen, wir
brauchen einiges, Dankeschön Quatsch mit Sauce für den Sub, so, wir brauchen einiges
an Parametern hier, so, Login-ID, Passwort, gerade mal ein bisschen kleiner, Login-ID,
Passwort, Session Expiration, das kommt auf, wir wollen übrigens Object an der Stelle
haben, ach, das geht nicht, er ist drauf, so, Timespan from Seconds, also, sagen wir mal,
10 Sekunden darf die Session gültig sein, Total Seconds, ja, man könnte jetzt einfach
10 reinschreiben, aber vielleicht will ich ja noch Minuten später machen, so, Session
Parameter, Api-Key, welchen Api-Key brauchen wir jetzt, jetzt brauchen wir den richtig,
echten Api-Key oder den Login Api-Key, welchen brauchen wir da jetzt, da muss ich hier nachgucken,
äh, Alter, ist das unübersichtlich, hier, was, Risk Context, was, ne, den Login Api-Key
braucht man hier wieder, ok, äh, also, Api-, ich glaube, ich guck, ich glaube, ich guck
in der JavaScript-Implementierung davon, guck ich mir das ab, also, Api-Key brauchen wir
mal wieder, Login Api-Key, ok, so, dann braucht man SDK, Bild, das haben wir schon, Format,
Target Enf, Leute, Target Enf, das packen wir in die Defaults rein, ich geh davon aus,
das brauchen wir noch öfters, Target Enf, wahrscheinlich können wir den Api-Key auch
in die Defaults reinpacken, so, SDK, also, Include, so, Include, was ist das hier, Profile
Data, E-Mails, ok, ich bin mir zwar nicht ganz, ganz sicher, aber wahrscheinlich was
er returnt, oder, von, von meinen Sachen, die da gespeichert sind, so, Target Enf, Hammer,
Include, Hammer, Include, User Info, User Info, Login Mode, Standard, was machen die
hier, Login Mode, haben die hier überhaupt Login Mode drinne stehen, Login Mode, Standard,
ok, das muss anscheinend sein, Login Mode, Standard, Language, juckt mich nicht, Source,
Show Screen Set, Alter, was auch immer, was auch immer, Auth Mode, Cookie, brauchen wir
noch, das ist wohl wichtig, ahja, das haben die da auch drinne, Auth Mode, Cookie, ok,
das war's, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, Kekwade, Alter, also, das Login kann jetzt
noch nicht funktionieren, ja, weil ich falsche, falsche Usernamen, Passwort eingebe, einmal
mal gucken, was der mir als Antwort, was der mir als Antwort, ähm, rausschmeißt, das
ist Ryder, das ist Ryder, Missing Required Parameter, APK, warum, der ist doch da, Missing
Required Parameter, erzähl, lüg nicht rum, der ist da, ich sehs genau, ihr sehts auch
oder, da steht eindeutig APK, nee, nee, muss APK nicht groß, das ist richtig so, äh,
ich hab's richtig, ach, Moment, wait a minute, da oben war's noch klein, und jetzt ist es
groß, Alter, das ist ja mal die geilste API aller Zeiten, die sie hier gebaut haben,
Missing Required Parameter, API Key, ok, soll ich jetzt exakt so schreiben, wie die das wollen,
ja, nee, nee, der sagt Missing Parameter, ok, ja, mach ich irgendwas falsch, Leute,
ok.
POST Invalid API Key Parameter, ah Joo
Also Login API Key, das ist doch der, den sie hier verwenden.
Ja, oder es ist wirklich so, weil mein Login nicht stimmt.
Geben wir mal irgendwie was ein, was nach E-Mail Adresse aussieht.
Nee, Missing Request, Invalid API Key Parameter, stimmt dir irgendwas nicht, was ich hier zu
ist?
Bin ich zu pepega, das hier zusammenzubauen?
Vielleicht mache ich das ja einfach falsch mit dem, mit dem Dictionary.
Wartet mal, wir testen das mal kurz, was da rauskommt.
Wir gucken mal, was da rauskommt.
Alter, was serialisiert der mir denn hier für ein Shit zusammen?
Das ist gar kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Okay, so funktioniert das nicht, das muss ich anders machen.
Das klappt so nicht, ich dachte, ich könnte das elegant machen mit den Default Parametern,
aber das scheint so weniger zu klappen.
Was kommt denn da überhaupt zurück, wenn ich zwei Dictionaries zusammen?
Ach, da kommt gar kein Dictionary zurück, oder wie?
Leute, warum kommt, wenn ich zwei Dictionaries zusammenschmeiße, warum kommt da kein Dictionary
zurück?
Das Chase zonifiziert das Dictionary, aber nicht so, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Okay, wir machen das anders.
Ich brauche diese Default Parameter garantiert noch öfters.
Das geht bestimmt schöner, nennen wir irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Default Parameters oder Union,
aber sowas gibt es glaube ich, das gibt es, ach doch, Moment, nee, da kommt es gleich
raus.
Ne, da machen wir das anders, so, wie gesagt, das geht bestimmt schöner, aber wir machen
das jetzt immer schnell so, also Default, Default Dictionary ist das da, wir schmeißen
das hier mal weg, Default Dictionary ist das hier, so, was hat er jetzt verschm- Alter,
das hab ich übersehen, wat, ach, da ist noch ein New drinne, so, Default Parameter,
als irgendwie, keine Ahnung, For Each, Default and, warum geht das nicht, ah, okay Leute,
das geht garantiert deutlich schöner, aber mir fällt grad nix ein, so, und jetzt kann
ich hier oben sagen, so, oh Shit, Alter, wenn das jetzt leer, das ist ja mega hässlich,
egal, wir ignorieren das jetzt einfach, okay, so, ja, du kannst zu Dictionary machen, da
musst du aber explizit nochmal die Keys angeben, was auch blöd ist, so, geht das jetzt, Moment,
hier Default Parameters, so, geht das jetzt, kommt jetzt was Sinnvolles bei raus, ah, Moment,
ich muss den, ja, ja, Ausgabe machen, Auth Response, was, Alter!
Was macht der denn da draus, das sieht doch gut aus, das sieht doch jetzt richtig gut
aus, APK, alles gut, wie hat der hier APK geschrieben, ist alles richtig, jetzt ist,
das ist gut so, das ist, so muss das sein, so ist das korrekt, so ist das eigentlich
richtig, warum funktioniert das nicht, eigentlich müsste das so jetzt gehen, Missing Required
Parameter APK, bin ich jetzt total hängen geblieben, der ist doch da, okay, okay, wir
machen jetzt, ich hab ne Idee, ich hab ne Idee, ist das gar kein, ist das gar kein Jason,
was man da postet, vielleicht, das ist das vielleicht gar kein Jason, was man da postet,
ist das irgendeine, ist das irgendwelche Forms, oder so, vielleicht, oh Leute, ich hab grad
auswendig den Chat zugemacht, cool, muss man Chat hin, muss den Chat refreshen, so, jetzt,
jetzt ist er wieder da, ich seh euch wieder, ist das vielleicht irgendwas, also das ist
das erste Get, das will ich net haben, das da interessiert mich, Response, was macht
der denn hier, Method Post, Join und Moment, das ist irgendeine Form, irgendeine Form,
hier guckt mal, Alter, das ist kein Jason Response, das ist irgendeine Form, ja gut,
wahrscheinlich weil er das gleiche aus dem Loginfeld zusammenbaut auf der Webseite, Post
Full Encoded Async, ok, schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert, ah, Invalid Login
or Password, das sieht schon deutlich besser aus, ok, meine E-Mail Adresse, die ist ja
bekannt, hier, wir sind, E-Mail Adresse, die da, ganz furchtbar, Fiat, please, so, nur
mit dem Passwort muss ich mir jetzt irgendwas überlegen, wir machen wieder eine Datei in
die ihr nicht rein, Secret, in die ihr nicht reingucken dürft, ihr dürft hier nicht reingucken,
ihr müsst ja alle die Augen zumachen, Leute, wenn ich das reinschreibe jetzt, Fiat, nee,
Secrets, jpw, ok, da zeigt das auch nicht an, ok, Augen zu Chat, Augen zu, keiner guckt,
Konfig, null, ich glaube es geht los, nee, kein Konfig, ok, so, passt, ihr dürft wieder,
ihr dürft wieder gucken, mache ich wieder an, Bildschirmhelligkeit hochlegen, oh nee,
jetzt hat er es gesehen, er hat mich durchschaut, so, Passwort, Secrets, Fiat Passwort, so, mal
schauen, ob es funktioniert, ich bin gespannt, easy, Login Token liegt, aber es sind 10 Sekunden
expired, Chat, Chat, viel Spaß das in 10 Sekunden abzutippen, wer schafft es, easy, bin drin,
oh nein, Chat, wusste doch, euch kann man nichts zeigen hier, man kann es ja verdammt
zeigen, du weißt ja noch gar nicht, was du mit dem Login Token überhaupt machen sollst,
ok, was bekommen wir denn hier für eine Response überhaupt, ok, Call ID, Error Code, API Version,
Status Code, Status Reason, ok, das klingt schon mal nicht schlecht, UID, die brauchen
wir auf jeden Fall, das weiß ich noch, die UID brauchen wir, sag mal, diesen ganzen Schmodder
brauch ich doch nicht, Profile, E-Mail, Data, ich mein, who cares, oder, nein, wen juckt
es, die UID brauche ich, sonst nix, so, dann würde ich vorschlagen, wir schnappen uns
das hier nochmal, wobei, nein, eigentlich, wir brauchen nix davon, oder, wir brauchen
nix davon, wir brauchen nur die UID, nur das da, sonst, sonst brauchen wir nix, so, das
ist doch, das ist doch easy, guck mal, äh, wir haben unsere Fiat Response, wir machen
jetzt, oh, wir sind heute Hyper Object Oriented, machen jetzt Public Class, so, das ist Fiat
Api Response Base, ne, Base, Base, das ist, äh, Auth Api Response, so, und das Ding hat
da nur ein extra Feld, was UID heißt, String, UID, so, äh, da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher,
JSON Property, ob man da angeben muss, wie das genau heißt, weil, hier heißt es ja UID,
da weiß ich, ob er, ob er es checkt, so, ähm, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert,
jetzt machen wir zu, so, und wir wollen jetzt nicht, wir wollen ein, ein JSON Response kriegen,
irgendwie Auth Response, schauen wir mal, Auth Response UID, gucken wir mal, ob wir jetzt
nur die UID rauskriegen, easy, funktioniert, so, UID haben wir, und die anderen Sachen
haben wir natürlich, Moment, ich wollte das natürlich erben, so, dass der andere Krempel
da auch drinne ist, genau, so, äh, was weiß ich, Auth, failed, so, gut, also, jetzt sind
wir zumindest schon mal einen Schritt weiter, wir haben jetzt, wenn ich jetzt richtig sehe,
Session Cookies und, und ein Token, nee, und die User ID, und die User ID, ok, wie geht
es jetzt weiter, wie geht es jetzt weiter mit dem, mit dem ganzen Shit hier, also, das
haben wir jetzt, passt hier, ganzen Krempel von Go, können wir mal ignorieren, jetzt müssen
wir ein Request auf Account get JSON Web Token machen, mit diesem ganzen Krempel hier drinne,
ok, na gut, guck mal, gut, dass wir unsere Base Sachen gespeichert haben, Pog, Leute,
wir brauchen den API Key doch bei jeder Anfrage, habe ich das jetzt bis jetzt richtig gesehen,
da können wir doch den API Key auch einfach, ach, Moment, hier ist der API Key groß geschrieben,
hier ist der API Key klein geschrieben, das ist bestimmt, nicht so, das, das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht, lassen wir das jetzt mal, also weiter gehts, das da müssen wir jetzt machen, also
wir brauchen ein Request, Copy Paste mir den Krempel hier mal, so, das hier ist ein JSON
Web Token Request Response, Login Uhr, jetzt auf Accounts, also wer sich das bei Fiat ausgedacht
hat, ne, Chat, bis jetzt bei Apple irgendwas spannendes dabei, irgendwas, irgendwas bahnbrechendes,
was man wissen müsste, außer das alles so easy, so awesome, so, so grandios ist, so
Cookies, der ganze andere Krempel hier ist wieder drinnen, das hier brauchen wir jetzt
Fields, Fields brauchen wir auf jeden Fall, den ganzen anderen, und das Token muss da
jetzt auch rein, ok, Auth Mode Cookie, ok, das muss man hier drinnen stehen lassen anscheinend,
also, ok, wir brauchen folgendes, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, wir brauchen Fields,
Fields ist dieser ganze Schmodder da, was auch immer man mir das sagen soll, Fields,
was denn hier, was denn hier, Rider denkt mit, Rider hör auf mitzudenken, lass mich
das tippen, so, Login Token brauchen wir jetzt noch, Login Token, woher kommen eigentlich
die ganzen Extension Methods, das kommt von, zeige ich dir, das hier, das kommt von Flurl,
das ist ein, ein HTTP Client URL Builder, finde ich viel angenehmer als den eingebauten
HTTP Client, guck, das ist das hier, ist auch recht beliebt, ja, Login URL ist ein String
und das sind alles, ist alles Extention, was ein 1 Hertz Display, boah krass, was die alles
machen bei Apple und was brauchen wir jetzt hier noch, Login Token und ins Login Token
müssen wir jetzt was packen, die UID, nee, Login Token, Moment, ich bin glaube ich eins
zu weit oder, wo, wo, wo hat er denn das hierher, wo, wo hat der, wo hat er die Session Info
her, kommt die irgendwo hierher, ah, Session Info steht da drinnen, ist das, ist das so,
habe ich, habe ich noch irgendwie hier oben sowas, Session Info, guck mal da, stand da
Session Info, ach guck mal da, Session Info, Login Token, wir brauchen gar nicht nur die
UID, wir brauchen auch noch das da, Session Info, ja gut auf geht's, Session Info, also
brauchen wir jetzt noch sowas hier, Session Info, so und das bekommt ein Login Token,
Login Token und ein Expires In, Expires In, weil man das wahrscheinlich gar nicht braucht,
so und das kriegt ein Property Session Info und dann sollte er diesen Kram eigentlich
ordentlich deserialisieren, hoffe ich mal, das heißt wir bekommen jetzt ein Session
Token, guck mal nochmal ob wir jetzt ein Session Token bekommen, schauen wir mal, ja, ja, UID
Session Token, alles klar, so, weil jetzt brauchen wir nämlich das Session Token an
dieser Stelle, so wie es aussieht, Login Token, also sprich von vorher brauchen wir jetzt
die Session Info und das Login Token und jetzt sollten wir einen ordentlichen Response kriegen,
Moment, ist das jetzt überhaupt wieder URL encoded oder ist das jetzt wieder was anderes,
oh Gott, also die Fiat API macht mich fertig, ist es jetzt, ja das ist wieder ein Post,
ne Moment, ist das jetzt überhaupt, ne, ne das ist jetzt wieder ein Get, das ist jetzt
wieder ein Get mit URL Parametern, also was die sich da ausgedacht haben, Get, Moment,
also dann brauchen wir nicht das hier, sondern Set Query Parameters, Get String Assign, so
schauen wir mal was da jetzt zurück kommt, ob da jetzt was sinnvolles als Antwort zurück
kommt, General Server Error, ok was habe ich nicht gecheckt, was ist hier verkehrt, General
Server Error, was habe ich hier verkehrt gemacht, Fiat Server geschrottet, Accounts, Get, so
passt, wir gucken uns die JavaScript Variante an, das haben wir jetzt ja schon, so hier
sind wir jetzt, also Login Talken haben wir, haben wir, haben wir, haben wir, haben wir
alles, was, was könnte ihn denn, was könnte ihn jetzt, der API Key fehlt doch bestimmt
wieder oder, der API Key fehlt garantiert, Chat, der API Key fehlt, sagts euch, der API
Key fehlt, hat der hier den API Key drinne, Login API Key, API Key, der API Key, der API
Key hab ich vergessen, aha, schon funktioniert's, schon funktioniert's, exellent, alles klar,
so den API Key, den machen wir jetzt hier wirklich mal raus und packen den in die Defaults
rein, der API Key und Auth Mode Cookie kommt auch in die Defaults rein, weil anscheinend
braucht man das immer, Auth Mode Cookie können wir wegmachen und API Key können wir auch
wegmachen, API Key, hoffentlich kann ich den API Key hier auch wegmachen, dann nicht, dass
es case sensitive ist, hey es funktioniert, die haben ihre API nicht case sensitive gemacht,
ich bin begeistert, es funktioniert mit API klein geschrieben und API groß geschrieben,
Pog, ich mein Login Mode Standard könnte ich da auch reinmachen, Login Mode Standard
machen wir auch da rein, das hier, das lassen wir mal, das sieht so aus als muss das da
nicht hin, ok, ok, ok, also wir haben jetzt ein Token, wir haben jetzt ein Token, hier
Idee, Idee Token, ist da sonst noch irgendwas spannendes drinne, nee nur Idee Token, ok,
objektorientiert sein ist anstrengend, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt eine Fiat Response
und die da haben da drinne bloß ein ID Token, Token ID, ah, get Jason Essink, Fiat Dings
Response, jawoll, schauen wir mal ob da was sinnvolles bei rumkommt jetzt, exellent, also
das hat übrigens alles keine Gimmick, ok hier ist unser Token, ok, jetzt, es wird ja
noch viel wilder, es wird ja noch viel wilder jetzt, also jetzt haben wir unser Web Token,
jetzt müssen wir zu Amazon, jetzt wird es erst richtig kriminell, kriminell, kriminell
wird es nicht bevor jetzt hier irgendwie wieder die Twitch und YouTube Polizei am Start ist,
nein nein, es wird kompliziert, mein Opa hat immer gesagt wenn es kompliziert wird
jetzt wird es kriminell, so was haben wir, oh jetzt müssen wir zu Amazon, jetzt müssen
wir zu Amazon, oder sowas in der Richtung, nee wir müssen nicht zu Amazon, wir müssen
nochmal zu Fiat und ok anscheinend müssen wir jetzt zu dieser
URL, alles klar, obviusly müssen wir dahin, also Token URL, so und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wie geht es jetzt, also Token URL und jetzt muss ich was für ein Request machen, jetzt
muss ich Header setzen Leute, ich gebe dir Header, x client API Version, was so, jetzt
mal ernsthaft, das ist doch abartig was die sich hier ausgedacht haben, sag mal das ist
ja ein Login Vorgang, der ist ja komplizierter, wie alles wirklich ohne Scheiß, ich habe
noch nie einen komplizierteren Login Vorgang gesehen, also was, ich habe keine Ahnung was
die sich dabei gedacht haben die Italiener, normalerweise würde ich jetzt sagen was die
China Chinesen dabei gedacht haben, es sind doch nicht mal die Chinesen diesmal, also
muss ich Header setzen Leute, Header, also erstmal unsere Cookies wieder anhängen, Cookies,
ohne unsere Cookies geht wahrscheinlich nichts, der Punkt muss eins runter, Cookies, so Header,
also wir brauchen eine x client API Version, ok, 1.0, dann brauchen wir eine, Moment, wir
brauchen eine Client Request ID, die aus einem random Stream mit 16 zei, also, also
was, was bin ich sehend hier Fiat, was ist das, was gibt das wenn es fertig ist, x API
Key, oh wir brauchen einen anderen API Key Leute, habe ich den schon, den habe ich noch
gar nicht, wir brauchen jetzt einen anderen API Key, wir brauchen jetzt den, den, den
x API Key, was ist denn der x API Key, ah hier, der da, natürlich, natürlich, einer,
einer reicht dann als selbstverständlich nett, Private String API Key, kann man den, kann
man den als API Key irgendwie Token API Key oder so nennen, dass ich deswegen halbwegs
unterscheiden kann, API Key, ok, Token API Key, alles klar, x Originator Type, Web, natürlich,
wir sind in Browser, habe ich nie was anderes behauptet, ok Client Request ID, meine Güte,
Client Request ID, also ein random, also ich soll jetzt einen random String generieren,
das ist der gleiche Key wie da rüber, echt, ne, zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar, zwei
komplett unterschiedliche paar Keys, this random String, ok Leute, wisst ihr was, ich,
ich mache es mir jetzt einfach, wobei ich muss mal gucken, was der da eigentlich macht,
random String, ah, der random String generiert sich aus nur kleinen Buchstaben und Null bis
neun, natürlich, was sonst, was sonst, du meinst den Auskommand, achso, hab ich gar
nicht gesehen, dass der oben schon hat, also nur kleinen Buchstaben und Null bis neun,
ok das ist relativ einfach Leute, wir machen, wir machen uns jetzt, wir machen uns jetzt
wirklich, wir machen uns jetzt wirklich einfach, ich hoffe der frisst das jetzt, Client Request,
wir sagen jetzt einfach, Gut, New, String, ohne was, 16, fertig, das ist random genug
oder, das, das müsste, müsste random, es müsste random genug sein für die glaube ich,
so, müssen wir sonst noch was machen, aha, das ist jetzt ein, ach, das ist jetzt ein
Post Request, ach, das ist jetzt ein Jason Post Request, ok, Post Jason Async, und da
muss jetzt was rein, Gigia Talken, was für ein Ding, Gigia Talken API, das hab ich ehrlich
gesagt noch nie gehört, warum heißt das nicht Gigia Chat Talken oder sowas, aber Gigia,
das bestimmt irgendwas von Amazon, oder ist das Chat, sagt euch das was, ich mein scheint
ja, scheint ja irgendwie verbreitet zu sein, aber ich hab das noch nie gehört, ok wo sind
wir stehen geblieben, hier, random String, was ist das, Moment, da bin ich ja noch gar
nicht, da bin ich noch gar nicht, hier, hier, login, login, header, ne Moment, da bin ich
auch noch nicht, wo muss ich denn hin, na, da bin ich, Gigia Talken, ok, Gigia Talken,
und das ist jetzt, ich lösche das hier mal, weil wir haben ja alles drinne, und das ist
jetzt quasi von der Response vorher, hallo, ah ne, Moment, gleich, wir sind hier nicht
in die Ava-Screen, äh, Talken ID, ok, es ist nicht die Talken ID, es ist tatsächlich
ein ID-Talken, das muss ich umbenennen, ok, und jetzt, äh, Receive String, jetzt bin
ich ja mal gespannt, ob da was Sinnvolles zurückkommt, Alter, Identity Response, ob
das jetzt funktioniert, Schatz, ich bin skeptisch, so, ich würde sagen, es hat funktioniert,
und jetzt bekommen wir eine Identity ID mit irgendeinem Amazon Rechenzentrum, beziehungsweise
Amazon Region, und nochmal ein Talken, sag mal, das wie viele Talken ist das jetzt, das
fünfte, der Identity Aid Identifier, also wenn du Sachen schon so benennen musst, da weißt
du, da stimmt irgendwas nicht so ganz, der Identity Identifier, alles klar, aber, aber
Leute, es hat funktioniert, lasst mal was testen, was passiert denn, wenn ich hier 16,
wenn ich hier einfach ein 17, 17-stelliges Random String mitschicke, geht es dann immer
noch, ja, funktioniert einfach trotzdem, müssen wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht 16 sein, ist
wahrscheinlich vollkommen egal, der erste Typ hat 16 genommen und jeder hat von ihm
abgeschrieben und seitdem waren es 16, ok, weiter, weiter, ok, also, was, Moment, was
bekommen wir da jetzt überhaupt als Antwort, Identity ID und Talken, ok, also, gehen wir
mal hier wieder runter, das können wir nicht von unserer Fiat Response ableiten, sondern
einfach nur, was ist denn das jetzt für eine Url hier, zeig mal, wie heißt die Url, Alter,
das ist, 0101 FCA Gizuf, FCA, das ist dieser Fiat Konzern, nenn es jetzt einfach, nenn
es jetzt einfach, keine Ahnung, FCA, Identity Response, irgendwie muss ich den Krempel nehmen,
so, Property, Identity ID, jawoll, ganz toll, String und noch ein Talken, noch ein Talken,
wir haben noch nicht genug Talkens, da sind auch immer andere Talken, wie man hier sieht,
guck, die sehen nur ähnlich aus, aber sind immer andere, also, Receive FCA Identity,
schauen wir mal, ob es funktioniert hat und bam, funktioniert, ok, jetzt haben wir noch
ein Talken und jetzt, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, müssen wir zu Amazon oder was
kommt jetzt für abgedrehter Shit, ich, Leute, ich spar mir, ohne Mist, ich spar mir einfach,
ich spar mir das Error Handling, Kacke, so, und hier mache ich gar kein Error Handling
mehr, so, wie geht es denn, wie geht es denn weiter, Talken, ID, Logins, jetzt muss ich
irgendwelche AWS Requests machen, was zum, gibt es da nicht irgendeine fertige AWS Library
für die ich nehmen kann, warum sollte ich diesen Krempel selbst zusammenbauen, Marfinius,
Dankeschön für den Host, das ist doch blödsinnig, ich brauche doch keine eigenen Amazon Requests,
gibt es doch irgendeine Amazon Library, die das für mich macht, wie machen das die Jungs
in golden hier drüben, die verwenden irgendeine Amazon Library, guckt mal, get credentials
for identity, genau das will ich haben, get credentials for identity,.net, AWS, ich suche
jetzt einfach mal nach ingnet.net, guck mal da, AWS SDK for.net, nach was muss ich da
suchen jetzt, AWS SDK, kennt sich irgendjemand damit aus, Cognito Identity, danach suche ich
mal, ich habe keine Ahnung von dem AWS Krempel, ok wir haben Cognito Identity Provider und
Cognito Identity, ok, ich habe absolut keinen Plan, wie verwendet man das jetzt, gibt es
ja irgendein Example oder so, Docs, Docs ist immer gut, Example, haha das ist gut, das
ist gut, das mache ich rein, das ist gut, das gefällt mir, ich habe es hinzugefügt,
das ist gut, was ist der Ziel des heutigen Projekts, das wird nicht nur heute sein, ich
will mein Elektroauto in Home Assistant drinne haben, also so Sachen wie Reifendruck, Batteriestatus
und Lade Dauer und sowas, ich brauche mal ein Beispiel dafür, Hot Examples, jawoll,
die Hot Examples, wo sind sie, was, gibt es da nicht irgendein Beispiel für Stack Overflow,
bin da jetzt echt ein bisschen aufgeschmissen, hat nicht einer von euch irgendwie Plan von,
ok was, was gibt es denn, was gibt es denn hier, Cognito Identity, schreibt man das überhaupt
so, Cognito Identity Provider Info, Cognito Identity Client, sowas da, ja, ja, ja, ja,
jetzt, boah wie viel Zeug, wie heißt das denn Get, so hieß das doch oder, ok das war
jetzt echt Luck, das war einfach nur pures Glück, ich habe random irgendwas genommen
und das ist, wobei das stand doch glaube ich sogar auch hier, keine Ahnung was ich mache
hier, E-Auto Review Incoming, bekommst du Geld oder Ladekarte, nö, war damit aber auch
nicht auf die Arbeit, so was muss man da jetzt reinschreiben, vielleicht wenn ich danach
suche finde ich vielleicht was, Issues, das ist gut, zeig mal Beispiel Code please, Request,
OKS, was, ok das ist die verwirrendste API die ich je gesehen habe, ich habe keine Ahnung
wie dieser Amazon Shit funktioniert, ok was machen die denn in der Go, was machen die
in der Go, also die sagen Get Credentials for Identity Input, wo kommt denn das jetzt
schon wieder her, wisst ihr was cool wäre, wenn die Go API und die.NET API von diesem
Amazon Zeug ungefähr gleich wären, ich habe keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert, also die
übergeben hier irgendwie Logins, ok also, ja GitHub ohne Scheiß, GitHub Copilot wäre
für sowas wirklich gut, ok Identity ID, ich habe hier eine Identity ID, Identity ID, ok
und jetzt, ein Dictionary, ah das machen die in Go auch, guck mal, die machen ein Dictionary
was Logins heißt, das einfach auch mal machen, Logins, ach das heißt schon, ok New Dictionary,
was ist denn das schon wieder für eine API Mann, was ist denn das hier, Await, das funktioniert
im Leben nicht, und dann das da und dann das Token rein, MonkaS Alter, Ident, nee, nee
und gleich, gleich, Identity Response, Token, ha, funktioniert nicht, nee, komm mal, exellent,
wie bist du auf die Fiat API von GitHub gekommen, gar nicht, ich habe Projekte gesucht die Fiat
zu porten und habe mir dann den Songscore angeguckt, du kannst dir EVCC angucken oder IO Broker
angucken, die haben beide Fiat Module, ok, jetzt schicken wir mal den Request ab Leute,
keine Ahnung was dabei rauskommt, was kriegen wir dann hier als Antwort eigentlich dann,
was, ja was bekommt man hier eigentlich für eine Antwort, was ist denn das hier, was kommt
da raus, Get Credentials for Identity Response, Identity Response habe ich schon, Credentials
for, exakt so muss das heißen, Credentials for Identity Response, das muss einfach immer
noch länger werden, ok Credentials, HTTP Status Code, ok auf gehts Leute, Bäm, komm
mal ob das jetzt funktioniert, äh, hallo, hallo, ist AWS immer so langsam, hallo, hallo,
was machen die, ah die muss, guck mal die geben noch die Region an, die geben noch die
Region an, alles klar, sendet er, oh er ist abgekackt, no region endpoint, aha, siehste,
region endpoint, west, oh jetzt aber, hängt wieder, ja, ich hab das noch nie verwendet,
ich weiß nicht wie man das jetzt richtig benutzt, example, ja zeig her, doch die Region stand
drinne, da stand EU West drinne, ok guck mal wir gucken uns mal das von Amazon an, guck
mal die setzen auch nur die Region, ok er ist wieder abgekackt, ich hab ja auch kein
Login für Amazon von Fiat, brauch ich ja auch nicht, ich will da drauf zugreifen mit
einem ganz normalen Request, ok was gibt's denn hier noch für Credentials, ok zeig mal
her, New Credentials, da muss ich jetzt AWS Keys und sowas eingeben, das hab ich net,
ich hab kein Secret Key, ich hab kein Session Tongue, ich hab kein Access Key, geil, oh
guck mal es gibt Anonymous AWS Credentials, sag mal wie viele Credentials gibt's denn
hier eigentlich, Anonymous Credentials, easy, Leute ich hab echt kein Plan, es hängt wahrscheinlich
wieder, alles klar, das kann doch nicht so ernsthaft so benutzt werden oder, und hat
das jetzt das gemacht was ich machen will, schauen wir mal, ich hab jetzt übrigens,
by the way, Credentials, ich bekomme jetzt übrigens, das ist jetzt das sechste Tongue,
das sechste und siebte Tongue, ich bekomme jetzt noch ein Session Tongue, ein Secret
Key und ein Access Key ID, das ist quasi dann das sechste, siebte und achte Tongue was ich
jetzt bekomme, also das ist ja so secure, das ist schon hyper secure, da kannst du keine
Chance mehr, wie viele, wie viele Tokens sind das jetzt, habt ihr mal mitgezählt, ich glaube
es sind wirklich, damit sind wir 9 Tokens, hoffentlich brauchen wir die nicht alle später
noch, Tokencounter, ok Credentials, die muss ich mir wahrscheinlich speichern denke ich
mal hier, Credentials, na komm, wir nennen es, wir nennen es mal nicht einfach nur C sondern
als Credentials, ok und damit mache ich jetzt genau was, bin ich jetzt damit fertig mit
dem Login, bin ich jetzt mit der Login Prozedur durch, bald brauchen wir einen Token Manager
zum verwalten, oh the Factory, Token Manager Factory brauchen wir da, so, Response Data
Token, Data ID, ja das haben wir alles gespeichert, was macht der denn jetzt damit, Amtsfeld,
der wusste auch nicht mehr was er hier reinschreiben soll, Seba, Suchan, 95 Dankeschön
für den Sub, ok und weiter, hey wir sind fertig mit dem Login, wait a minute, jetzt
können wir unsere Autos auflisten lassen, die nicht vorhanden sind aber ok, zumindest
der Request zum auflisten der Autos sollte funktionieren, exellent, Leute wir haben es
geschafft, wir sind eingeloggt, wir haben es geschafft in nur, in nur, na so viel Zeilen
sind es gar nicht, 32, also 60 Zeilen haben wir gebraucht für das Login, ich mein es
ist, das ist wirklich kompliziertes Login Verfahren was ich hier gesehen habe, ok also
Private Credentials, Moment ist das überhaupt das richtige, das sind die richtigen Credentials
hier, zack, jetzt lasse ich einfach die IDE machen, einfach hier zack, gibt es nicht,
Create Field Credentials, fertig, ok die ID brauche ich auf jeden Fall später noch, UID,
wo gab es, in welchem Response war die ID hier, Auth Response war die UID, die UID brauche
ich auf jeden Fall noch, Private String, User ID, User ID, die gab es nämlich hier, User
ID gleich, ok jetzt können wir den Request machen und die ganzen Autos auflisten lassen
wenn ich das hier richtig sehe, dazu brauchen wir das, mein Gott ist das abartig Alter zu
bedienen, ok also das Login hat ja anscheinend funktioniert so wie es aussieht, boah wie
viel kostet das neue iPhone, 1450 Euro, das ist ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen richtiger
Schnapper, aber die Leute werden es garantiert bezahlen, ich meine Leute, denkt an die Inflation,
Apple muss auch überleben irgendwie, Apple ist bestimmt ja schon kurz vor der Pleite,
die können sich das nicht leisten, da ein bisschen weniger fürzunehmen, das geht nicht,
mittlerweile bekommt man dafür sogar eine Grafikkarte plus einen CPU schon, seit die
ganzen Miner ihre Grafikkarten loswerden wollen bzw. sich das Minen nicht mehr lohnt, also
Login hat funktioniert, jetzt geht es weiter, Public, Task, Public Async, Task, ich nenne
es einfach nur Patch, so und da rufen wir jetzt die Auto Infos ab, die wir nicht abrufen
können, weil der Account keine Autos hat, aber der Request muss funktionieren, ja ich
lege überhaupt keinen Useragent fest, das interessiert die auch überhaupt nicht, so
was ist das hier jetzt eigentlich, das kann ich mir doch bestimmt auch wieder alles sparen,
ok wir gucken uns das mal in Go an, da muss ich glaube ich in die andere Datei, Vehicle,
also das muss ich jetzt aufrufen, Api-Uri, ok welche ist das jetzt, Ah das ist wieder
was anderes, ok, also wir brauchen noch eine weitere Url, die wir abrufen können, na dann,
also das ist jetzt die richtig echte Api-Url, ok, nicht irgendwie die Login-Url oder die,
das ist jetzt die richtig echte Api-Url, die wir jetzt brauchen für die weiteren Requests,
na dann hoffen wir mal, Api, den nicht net so, ups, so heißt das, Api-Url, so get, was
machen die hier jetzt, Stage, Moment was, wait, Seg, Seg, die Domains sind extrem PP'er
von den, also, Append-Segment, V2, nee, V4, V2 war bei dem anderen, V4, Accounts, äh,
jetzt brauchen wir die ID, User ID, FCA, GCV, das ist irgendwas für Fiat, Chrysler, sonst
was, nicht der FCA, Fiat, Fiat Chrysler Automobiles, was GCV ist habe ich keine Ahnung, Growth
Capital Venture, alles klar, Big Stonks, äh, warum geht das jetzt nicht, ah Segments muss
es sein, Pass Segments, User ID, ok, Vehicles und jetzt Query-Parameter, wenn wir da gar
nicht ganz sicher sind, doch, ne, Set Query-Parameter, genau, hier steht ja auch da oben Stage, all,
da kommt doch im Leben nix Gescheites raus, hier Api-Url, so, also, V4 Accounts, was,
was muss man da jetzt noch alles angeben, nix oder wie, ne, das kann ja so schon mal
nicht funktionieren, Cookies wahrscheinlich, bestimmt, bestimmt Cookies, garantiert Cookies,
garantiert Cookies, ah ne, das Cookie habe ich ja, ja dann keine Cookies, ähm, woher
muss ich denn jetzt was ich da angehe, die geben mir gar nix an in dem Request, was macht
denn V-Request, V-Request, V-Request, was ist denn V, also Beschissene hätten wir
ja nicht benennen können, was ist V, V-Api, ah Moment, hä, was ist V, Request New, kommt
das, kommt das hier her, ne, das hatte ich gerade auf, ach ne, hier ist es doch, da ist
es doch, aha, ok, diesen ganzen, diesen ganzen Crap muss ich da wieder anhängen, dass es
funktioniert, alles klar, ok, das wäre ja auch zu einfach gewesen, wenn das nicht,
wenn das einfach nur abgeschickt werden kann, also, ähm, Append Path Segment, Set Query
Parameter, Header Braumer, with Header, äh, x, x, komm wir schreiben es, wir schreiben
es klein, machen das wie dem, wie in dem JavaScript Beispiel, x, Client App Version, 1.0, so,
Client Header, Client Request ID, Moment, das ist der gleichen Krämpel wie da oben,
oder?
Lul, Ease, so, was braucht man da sonst noch, x-Api Key, x-Api Key, haben wir das da oben
auch gebraucht, x-Api Key, jawoll, zack, Copy Paste, beste, Originator Type, Web, haben wir
oben auch gebraucht, ok, wunderbar, haben wir jetzt alles, Pin Auth, das haben wir eh
nicht, also, das haben wir, das haben wir, das haben wir, das haben wir, das haben wir,
except, äh, except, können wir vielleicht noch machen, with Header, except, ob wir das
brauchen, das Ding wird wahrscheinlich standardmäßig immer, Application, JSON, äh, Antworten, Content
Type, ähm, Leute, mal ne doofe Frage, aber, die machen doch, die senden doch hier überhaupt
keine Daten, warum setzen die in Content Type, ich mein, wenn ich keine Daten sende, muss
ich eigentlich auch kein Content Type setzen, aber wir machen, ich mein, wer weiß, was die
Fiat API da haben will, wir machen das jetzt einfach so, ok, also, jetzt haben wir alles
gesetzt, wo setze ich meine Credentials überhaupt, ich mein, die habe ich abgerufen, irgendwo
müssen die doch jetzt mal, was, was Sinnvolles machen, mal gucken was die API sagt, mal gucken,
mal gucken was passiert, äh, Get, String, so, mal gucken was da jetzt zurückkommt,
gleich mal her, flup, flup, flup, flup, flup, äh, forbidden, forbidden, ja gut, ich hab
ja auch nirgendswo meine Credentials angegeben, forbidden, ähm, wir können das mal in einem
zwei Catchplot machen, weil ich glaube, man kriegt aus der Exception noch ein bisschen,
noch ein bisschen mehr raus, Message vielleicht, äh, äh, vielleicht kann man da was rauslesen,
Response, Get, String, Async, Missing Authentification Token, ja genau, wie gebe ich denn das jetzt
an, das Authentification Token, Identity Sign, jetzt muss ich irgendwelche AWS Signaturen
oder, was ist das, jetzt schon wieder, mein Gott, was haben die sich da ausgedacht, Alter,
ok, AWS 4 Sign, jetzt hört es aber auf, jetzt hört es aber auf, was ist denn das jetzt
schon wieder, AWS 4 Sign, der Signed irgendwie die Header und dann, und dann kopiert er sich
den Authorization Header, ey, wer hat sich das ausgedacht, Mann, wer hat sich das ausgedacht,
ok, was machen die in Go, Identity Sign, ok, ich guck mal kurz, was da passiert, vielleicht
gibt es ja auch schon eine fertige Amazon Library, dann nehmen wir die, Identity Sign, ok, Sign,
noch ein Fett, New Signer, alles klar, wir signen mit dem Signer, mit welchem Signer,
Stack Overflow, Leute,.net, AWS Sign V4, Stack Overflow, was denn das, AWS Signer V4.net,
das klingt gut, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, was man braucht, aber der Name klingt
vielversprechend, müsst ihr zugeben, oder, klingt genau nach sowas, was ich brauch, AWS
Signer V4.net, Sign HTTP Request Messages Using AWS Signature Version 4, bitte schön,
also nicht irgendwie outdated V2 oder sowas, Version 4, ne, wenn die V2 war die, war die
Client Version, also nicht V3, oder was, Using Request Information and Credentials, ich weiß
doch nicht mal, was ich überhaupt vor mir hab, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich hier sehe,
ich weiß nicht, was ich hier machen soll, ok, Stack Overflow, is there a.net Library,
was kann das sein, Request mit, ist immer, ganz, ganz bescheuerte Frage, aber warum brauche
ich eine extra.net Library, um Request für AWS zu signen, wenn Amazon noch 30 Milliarden
.net AWS Libraries hat, also warum kann das die nicht einfach, ja, Python interessiert
mich, ne, wirklich, was sind das wieder für Ppega Leute bei Stack Overflow, ja, der erste
verlinkte eine Python Library und der zweite verlinkte eine Javascript Geschichte, was
ist da schon wieder los, ok, Python Time, aktivieren, here is designer from SDK, ok,
er ist schön, wenn das designer da drin ist, I'm the co-author of this Library, welche
von, von was sprechen die da schon wieder, Nougat Packages, Amazon, AWS Signer.net,
das hatten wir doch gerade schon mal, oh es gibt auch noch ein AWS, AWS 4 Request Signer
für.net und es gibt ein AWS Signature Version, was zum Teufel, was bin ich sehen, was ist
das überhaupt, chat blickt irgendjemand durch, was das ist, hat irgendjemand schon was mit
AWS gemacht, AWS Signature Version 4, HTTP Client, ok, Credentials, ok gut, ok gut, das
kriege ich hin, das kriege ich hin zu benutzen, so und dann muss ich, dann muss ich was machen,
please execute AP, Region EU West, ok, also was brauche ich jetzt, welches Nougat Package
ist das hier, der AWS Signature, AWS Signature Signer, der AWS Signature Signer V4, ich
installiere das jetzt einfach mal als Package, ich weiß weder wozu ich das brauche, noch
was es macht, aber das wird schon irgendwie gehen, so, copy paste, ja gut, die benutzen
HTTP Client, HTTP Client will ich nicht verwenden, ich will Fluchel verwenden, das wird jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen komplizierter, ich könnte einen Hook registren, ja, before requests,
call, war mal ein Vorschlag, IDE, call, perfekt, so wunderbar, ne jetzt haben wir doppelt,
was call zu nennen ist ziemlich, ziemlich, naja da heißt es halt call, so und ich brauche
hier nämlich einen, ach nee, ah das ist ein Overload, das ist ein Overload von GetAsync,
ok wir müssen mal kurz das, die compile lassen, gucken was die da machen, oh guys, alter was
ein Gefurl man, GetAsync, GetAsync, hier, nee, was, nee, credentials, ja, wo macht der
hier was, immutable credentials, GetAsync, send self, ok, wir nähern uns, wir nähern
uns der Sache, hier, signer, sign async, also was, signer, Moment den signer gibt es jetzt
in Amazon und in AWS Signage, ok wir wollen AWS Signage, signer, sign, und jetzt, Leute
ich hab selten so wenig verstanden, was ich mache, was als hier gerade, signer, sign,
und was signiere ich überhaupt, versteht irgendjemand was ich überhaupt signen muss,
ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung, ok was muss ich da, requests, ok das weiß ich zumindest
schon mal was wir brauchen, wir brauchen, request message, ja das ist ok, das hab ich
verstanden, request message, a base, base url, gar keine, darf die null, nein, nein,
darf die null sein, ich hoffe mal, dass die null sein darf, ich hab, ich hab kein Plan
alter, default headers, was für default headers, ok, einfach leere Liste, einfach ja perfekt,
leere Liste, alles gut, date, time, now, ich brech mal kurz die Zeilen um, jetzt, jetzt
github co-pilot Leute, vielleicht wüsste der besser Bescheid was ich machen muss als
ich selbst, und jetzt string region name, region, end point, west, und jetzt credentials, ok,
was hat er für schmerzen, was, oh, ich hab zu wenig übergeben, du hast vergessen, ah
service name hab ich vergessen, ah service name, execute ap war das service name, aha,
guckte mal da, scheint so funktionieren, außer das da, eu west geht nicht, eu west system
name, wahrscheinlich, oder display name, wahrscheinlich system name, a credentials marker, ok, ok,
das marker nicht, warum nicht, weil es müssen immutable credentials sein, na meinetwegen
immutable credentials, excess key, credentials, secret key, hocken mehr gibt es da net, ok,
und das soll jetzt gehen, ich glaub nicht, dass das funktioniert, wir wollen mal run,
invalid request, ah moment, das ist aber schon mal was anderes, request parameter is missing
or invalid, aha, das ist schon mal was anderes, vorher hat er nämlich gesagt, passt mal auf,
wenn ich das nämlich weglasse hier, dann sagt er, verbinden, missing token sagt er
dann, also das ist schon mal richtig was ich hier mache, aber irgendwas ist missing, request
parameter is missing, welcher request parameter könnte missing sein, setz mal base uri auf,
meinste, wo krieg ich den überhaupt raus, ich bin auch richtig lost, ich hab keine Ahnung
was da passiert, vielleicht gehts jetzt ja, invalid request parameter, was, der sagt mir
ja auch nicht, welcher, welcher request parameter könnte denn da missing sein, weil wenn ich
mir das hier mal zum Vergleich angucke, was die go dudes machen, na gut das erkennt man
nicht richtig, was macht der IO Broker Typ, hab ich, hab ich nicht, moment, das hab ich
da nicht drinne, vielleicht, vielleicht brauche man das, vielleicht brauche man hier, weil
es sonst nicht geht, keine Ahnung, nein, fuck, ok, ich hab alles, xapkey hab ich, hätte
gesagt wenns nicht geht, client app hab ich, originator hab ich, ah, moment, das setzt
aber diese signing library ziemlich sicher, welcher request parameter könnte denn da missing
sein, mach ich ein get oder mach ich ein post, welcher request, der nimmt ne andere url, das
können wir ausprobieren, ich kann mir die url einfach ausgeben lassen, url, also der
ändert die ja ab hoffe ich mal, ne das ist ok, was in go, ne der nimmt doch keine andere
url, der sagt hier execute ap, das ist die, diese funktionsname, die hab ich ja auch,
dem java script, ja der hat die url unterteilt in host und pass, das dürfte eigentlich das
gleiche sein, wo ist das problem, wir geben uns mal die header aus, for each, rttp, message
request header, header, header, key, was die keys sind vertauscht, echt wo, wo, ne, ne
ist doch nix vertauscht, wo hab ich was vertauscht, also header accept bla bla, wo ist denn, wo
ist mein content type hin, chat mein content type ist weg, guck mal da, kein content type
header mehr, der hat sich einfach ausm staub gemacht, also wo ist denn jetzt mein, warum
ist da kein content type header mehr, wo ist der denn hin, ich setze den hier und unten
ist er weg, keck bei, ahja gut, call, rttp, message, header, add, da füge ich ihn halt
wieder hinzu, da kenne ich jetzt nix, so, ah moment, die schleife hätte ich mir mal
da lassen sollen, so, ah, jetzt ist er wieder da, vielleicht lag es ja da dran, oh, oh,
misused header name, content type, jetzt möchte mich dotnet wieder davor beschützen
irgendwas komisches zu machen, aber dotnet du musst mich nicht beschützen, ich will
absicht, ich will content type reinschreiben, die ist unter anderem auch für den 500e ja,
aber die geht wahrscheinlich auch dann für die anderen modelle, die uconnect verwenden,
make sure request headers are used with rttp request message, response header with rttp
response message, and content headers, rttp content, soll ich hier irgendwie sowas setzen
oder wie, ich mein, ich kann den content setzen, die sache ist nur die, ich weiß überhaupt
nicht, was, ich brauch gar kein content, ok, wisst ihr was, bitchy band jetzt einfach,
new string content, leerer string, encoding utf8 und media type, was, media type header
value, also ich will einfach nur, dass da application json drin steht, so, bitchy banden
den jetzt einfach, wir tun einfach so, als ist ein content dran, der ist leer, so bam,
aber wahrscheinlich liegt es nicht an dem, wait a minute, es hat keinen fehler gegeben,
moment, guck dir mal, warte, aber content type ist immer noch nicht da, ich hab jetzt
in leeren content angehängt, das geht jetzt oder was, hä, muss man das in irgendeiner
art und weise verstehen, ok, gucken wir uns mal den response an, easy, funktioniert, ok,
ich hab keine autos registriert, bei 4 mit dem neuen account, ja, aber das funktioniert,
guckt euch das mal an, also man muss ernsthaft einen leeren content setzen, dass das funktioniert,
ja, ok, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, wenn ich ehrlich bin, aber ich muss das ja auch
nicht denken, es reicht ja, wenn es funktioniert, broken api, also die api ist wirklich richtig
pepega, wir können jetzt noch mal hier was schickes draus machen und zwar, wir können
hier sowas machen wie aws sign, sowas, overload, generate, äh, kann man da irgendwie extension
methods generaten, anscheinend, dann mach ich das von hand in meinem helper file, public
static void, aws sign, credentials, so, ähm, this, was ist denn das, plural request oder
sowas, request, ah, ah, ah, credentials, was, reach an endpoint provider v2, was will
das ding von mir, ah, ich hab den falschen signer importiert, ah, ich, ich muss es nochmal
löschen, amazon, ja, ja, geh weg, signer, ich will den da haben und hier will ich, wahrscheinlich
das da haben und hier will ich wahrscheinlich das da haben, meine güde, äh, ok, jetzt
hab ich immer noch credentials, immer noch da, jawoll, perfekt, excellent, so, ah ne,
jetzt muss ich das noch return, return, return request, so und jetzt, ja, ist ja gut, hier,
ja, guck, jetzt, jetzt gehts, exellent, guck mal, jetzt ist das sogar richtig lesbar, oder,
wo erstmal gleich was abgeht, zack, funktioniert, das ist gar nicht mal so übel, muss ich sagen,
muss ich sagen, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, oh, das try catch kommt wieder weg, ups, äh,
schön sie schaben, ja, beste, beste sprache, das ist jetzt sogar relativ lesbar, muss ich
sagen, dadurch, dass ich den kram hier ausgelagert hab, ist das wirklich ganz ok, man könnte
sich jetzt vielleicht noch überlegen, ob man hier x client version, x apk, x originator
und so, ob man noch so nen, sowas hier macht, nur für das, nur für diesen krempel da,
beides sind header, ne, with, kann man da auch mehrere anhängen, mit headers, headers, object
headers, ja, ja, kann man, dann machen wir doch mal sowas hier, Leute, das ist eklig,
da musst du irgendwas schöneres geben, das anzuhängen, oder, copy paste, default, AWS
oder so, yes, ne, wie haben wir es genannt, default, header, ah, man, ok, header, so,
dann nehmen wir den krempel mal um, ah, header, ja, ja, ah, gut, ich will es nicht sehen,
das ist hässlich, aber das ist auf jeden fall besser, als jedes mal den gleichen kram hinzuschreiben,
du findest das problematisch, dass die Sachen in der cloud sind, ja, ich finde es auch nicht
schön, aber was willst du machen, ne, in dem Fall ist es halt so, entweder greife ich
die Sachen über die cloud ab, oder gar nicht, vielleicht hat man mal später die Chance,
das über den bluetooth debug interface vom auto abzugreifen, aber aktuell gibt es quasi
noch nichts, was den aktuellen fiat 500e ordentlich unterstützt, das heißt, ich muss
das über die cloud abgreifen, in zwei, drei jahren, wenn dieses cloud abo ausläuft, was
dabei ist, wo ich mir dann, je nachdem was es kostet, wirklich auch hart überlege, das
zu verlängern, also nicht zu verlängern, dann gibt es vielleicht irgendwelche debug
interfaces, die man dranstecken kann und per bluetooth auslesen oder so, das wäre mir natürlich
auch deutlich lieber, als hier irgendwas über die cloud zu machen, keine frage, also wir
brauchen das da, das da, das da, das ist alles das default zeug, was man immer braucht,
also, zack, zack, zack, x header, guck mal hier, wer das nicht checkt, was ich vor habe,
wäre nämlich, hatte ich gescheit einrücken, direkt hier, und da geht´s wirklich alles
Alter kannst du das mal gescheit einrücken Format jawoll so und jetzt können wir nämlich
an der stelle sagen with headers und dann AWS default headers ach nee das ist heim
default ist null oder ja das geht nicht da muss mir etwas schöneres ausdenken als hier
ein leeres objekt zu übergeben das ist hässlich rust des das habe ich gesehen auf github ja
das ist eher team viewer alternative glaube wenn ich das wenn ich das richtig erkannt
habe du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du das kann ich eigentlich kann ich mir
das alles sparen fertig das kommt weg aber noch nicht reich doch und das und das bräuchte
ich dann auch nicht extra sondern ja und es einfach so machen so wo brauchen die die default
headers noch da so mal gucken ob du alles funst ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt 500 e gekauft
vor zwei wochen ja funst noch alles exzellent du du du du du du du du ich bin begeistert
ich meine das war jetzt sehr abartig wie viel reichweite also ich habe es noch nie leer
gefahren also irgendwas so um 270 280 kilometer was das für ein wartungsintervall hat also
wenn du vier fragst dann alle sieben bis achttausend kilometer ob ich das mache weiß ich nicht
ich meine ich brauche dafür jeden jahr bis ich die gefahren bin oder so und muss nicht
sein ich meine aber für firmware updates und so vielleicht weil du kannst nicht alles
OTA updaten nee ich glaube es sind 7000 ich glaube es ist so was wie ein Jahr oder 7000
oder oder irgendwie so oder oder 7000 oder in den jahr irgendwie so ja du musst das auto
die firmen wir mussten firmen wir updaten lassen in der werkstatt jetzt mal ernsthaft
ich finde das ist halbwegs gut lesbar hier sogar guck mal ich mein man man versteht direkt
was passiert es ist halt die api von fiat ist halt eklig es fack aber man versteht es
und es funktioniert alles so wir können jetzt natürlich mit meinen credentials hier im stream
nicht weitermachen also normalerweise müsste ich jetzt um weiter zu machen hier das austauschen
durch meinen echten account und nicht durch diesen fake account weil naja der fake account
hat ja keine autos registriert wie ihr hier seht aber es ist alles nicht schlimm denn
ich habe schon eine ein anonymisierten response von meinem auto hier als jason feil die würde
man jetzt also normalerweise läuft es jetzt so hier würde mir als antwort also habe ich
im browser so gesehen also man kann ja browser network tab machen und im netzwerk tab von
der seite kann man sich die die requests angucken also man bekommt hier eine fahrzeug id zurück
und mit der fahrzeug id kann ich dann den weiteren request machen wo ich dann hier die
ganzen vehikel infos bekomme wo dann unter anderem so sachen drinne stehen wie kilometerzähler
wie weit muss ich fahren dass die batterie leer ist reifendruck öllevel was es nicht
gibt driestatus und so ja und man kann über die api wohl auch klimaanlage und sowas einschalten
was natürlich auch ganz nützlich ist was du machen kannst du kannst danach in deine
heim automatisierung dein auto einbinden du kannst dann zum beispiel in deine heim automatisierung
also einmal anzeigen lassen sachen wie ladet zustand von einer batterie bei wieviel prozent
die ist wieviel kilometer du damit fahren kannst ob dein reifendruck ok ist und sowas
kannst du dir alles anzeigen lassen und du kannst auch buttons machen zum beispiel zum
vorklimatisieren vom auto also wenn du sagst ich fahre in fünf minuten los ist es 38 grad
draußen ich würde schon mal die klimaanlage anmachen kannst hier einen button rein machen
kannst du kannst du kannst total viel abfragen das weiß ich aus dem kopf gar nicht alles
du kannst ab du kannst aufschließen abschließen das will ich würde ich jetzt aber nicht unbedingt
empfehlen du kannst licht anmachen du kannst hupen das würde ich auch nicht unbedingt
empfehlen du kannst du kannst ein paar sachen machen ich weiß aus dem kopf du kannst relativ
viel machen ja du kannst zum beispiel gucken ob der stecker angesteckt ist also sprich ist
der lade stecker angesteckt das siehst du hier dran an dem plug plug in status wenn
das auf true steht kannst du sehen ok das ist angeschlossen dann kannst du halt gucken
du kannst es dann beispielsweise sagen hey wenn es angeschlossen ist dann refresh mir
alle viertel stunde mal und sagt mir dann alle viertel stunde wie voll jetzt der akku
ist und dann kannst du gucken und wenn der akku voll ist und dann beispielsweise sagt
hier charging status ist nicht mehr charging lässt du dir zum beispiel eine push notification
schicken auto ist voll oder keine ahnung oder wie auch immer man darauf reagieren will
oder du kannst dir ok sagen wir mal was realistischeres mal was realistischeres ja der liest aus wie
voll die batterie ist und dann machst du eine automatisierung das wenn es keine ahnung
ist es abends 21 uhr 22 uhr 23 du gehst ins bett das kriegt der home assistant mit je
nachdem wenn es gescheit gemacht hast du gehst ins bett und sagen wir du hast vergessen das
auto zu laden und laden und die batterie ist nur noch bei 30 prozent dann könnte die push
notification schicken und sagen ey alter du bist grad ins bett aber dein auto ist noch
bei 30 prozent batterie und es ist auch nicht eingesteckt und dann kannst du noch mal in
hof flitzen und schnell anschließen über nacht aufladen alternativ kannst du dein auto
auch morgen nicht wach hupen lassen ja das kannst du allerdings nur machen wenn nicht
so viele leute drum herum wohnen wie bekommst du die daten später in home assistant rein
über home assistant mqtt discovery bekomme ich die rein kannst du mit der api auch das
laden pluppieren somit bis zu maximal 85 prozent laden aero zati weiß ich wie man es richtig
ausspricht aber dankeschön für den zapp da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher was der unterstützt
alles das einfachste dürfte sein du hast ein ladegerät was du ausschalten kannst remote
dann würdest du es nämlich so machen das müsste man mal gucken also zum beispiel wir
gucken mal beim iow broker rein was der hier unterstützt an ihr deep refresh zene charge
anscheinend kann man das ein und ausschalten würde ich jetzt mal vermuten ok command update
location warum über mqtt und nicht über die home assistant api weil es über mqtt
viel viel einfacher ist finde ich kannst auch über die home assistant api machen wobei
standardmäßig ist die htp api glaube ich sogar aus nicht standardmäßig die htp api
sogar aus doch die ist standardmäßig aus doch die ist aus du kannst ihnen den rest
denn so anlegen in der config zumindest über mqtt ist viel viel einfacher gerade auch wenn
du zwei wenn du bidirektionale kommunikation brauchst weil ich mir gar nicht sicher bin
ob ich das brauche in dem fall über mqtt ist wirklich simpel du kannst über mqtt auch
die ich mach mal aus wir machen heute kein home assistant ok du kannst über mqtt das
auch gruppieren lassen zu zu die weißes die dann sensoren drunter haben das ist viel wenn
ich gehe noch nicht ins bett leute ich habe home assistant ausgemacht also es ist viel
einfacher als über die api mit mqtt was natürlich noch einfacher wäre ist achso darksone
machst gut was natürlich noch viel einfacher wäre ist wenn man eine direkte home assistant
integration macht was gegen eine direkte home assistant integration für mich spricht ist
erstens habe ich noch nie gemacht zweitens ich muss den kram in python programmieren mit sachen
die ich noch nie verwendet habe hält sich mein spaß in grenzen und man kann container wenn es
mal probleme gibt auch einfacher neu starten und wenn die fiat integration langsam ist aus
irgendwelchen gründen macht es nicht meinen ganzen home assistant langsamer gut ich mein man muss
man sollte die integration also die home assistant integrations e asynch laufen lassen aber trotzdem
ist mir lieber zumal in home assistant addon auch easy ist du klickst den web interface addon
installieren wählst das fiat addon aus und gut ist musst du noch deine muss nur noch user namen
password hinzufügen also guck das sind die kommandos die man senden kann also man kann sagen
unlock lock das weiß ich nicht ob ich das wirklich als button einbauen will ich will
eigentlich mein auto nicht anlocken remote aber ok geht das über es geht immer übers
internet der fiat hat ein lte sim karte mit lte drinne und darüber wird kommuniziert du kannst
aber auch live die position abfragen also wenn irgendjemand mit deinem auto rum fährt dann
kannst du gucken wo das gerade ist und sowas alles stalken also du kannst du kannst abschließen
du kannst aufmachen du kannst die position abfragen du kannst das licht einschalten du kannst den
kofferraum zumachen du kannst den kofferraum aufmachen du kannst strom anschalten strom
ausschalten da steht zwar engine aber im prinzip ist strom an strom aus für die systeme innen
drinne du kannst blinken lassen dass man sehen kann wo das auto gerade steht du kannst die
alarmanlage ausschalten du kannst ihn laden lassen wenn er grad noch nicht lädt wie auch
immer das funktionieren soll weil er lädt ja eigentlich immer wenn man einstöpselt
das gibt es nicht du kannst die klimaanlage einschalten ich hoffe man kann damit die
klimaanlage auch wieder ausschalten weil weil stellt euch mal vor ihr schaltet die
klimaanlage ein weil ihr in fünf minuten los wollt dann ruft jemand an und sagt ach
hier es fällt aus und dann bleibt die für immer an oder wie das kann das kann es ja
nicht sein vielleicht vielleicht muss ich dann engine off senden wenn ich es ausschalten
will die lade steckdose ist noch nicht in der garage aktuell lade ich noch aus der steckdose
weil ich noch kein elektriker gefunden habe der mir das ding an die wand schraubt beziehungsweise
das schrauben ist ja nicht das problem an die wand dass das kabel im keller anschließen
hast du schon geschaut wie man das auto flaschen kann ja ich habe zumindest geschaut wie man
man mit irgendwelchen debugger entran kommt um sachen auszulesen aber es gibt noch keine
guten debugger für den neuen 500 e und was geht es gerade ich will mein neues auto in
die heim automatisierung einbinden wir haben es zumindest schon geschafft heute das war
tatsächlich erfolgreicher als ich gedacht habe wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft dass
ich mich einloggen kann bei fiat über die api und dort meine autos abfragen kann mit
einem fake account der keine autos hat aber ich logg mich hier im stream nicht mit meinem
echtem echtem account ein doch die handwerks plattform gibt es schon aber das hat ja keiner
hat er keine zeit ich meine ich habe ich habe bei sieben oder acht elektriker mittlerweile
angerufen die haben alle wartezeiten von wochen eher monaten und bei einem habe ich angerufen
und er meinte schon ganz am anfang deutsche deutsches kollege nicht da was was ich wollen
habe ich schon was ist da los gut ist ja nicht schlimm erzählste mal habe ich ihm erzählt
ja ich will mir ladegerät im hof installieren lassen und also ein elf kilowatt ladegerät
bla bla bla und ob die das machen und dann meinten sie ja das machen sie und dann war
die antwort nur noch da war die antwort darauf von ihm das wird das wird kosten das wird
kosten 900 euro da habe ich mir gedacht okay dass er jetzt ein bisschen scam wenn er die
sache noch nicht gesehen hat und keine ahnung hat was er machen muss dass er gleich sagen
wird das wird kosten 900 euro da habe ich mir gedacht zu denen gehe ich nicht also das
hat mir das war mir zu zu zu scam wenn das erste ist was die eine erzählt das wird kosten
das weiß ich also das war wahrscheinlich der einzige der zeit hatte aber den will ich nicht
und die anderen haben alle keine zeit ja natürlich 900 euro sind viel zu viel also ich meine
realistisch betrachtet muss der muss dann verlängerungskabel legen und so ein kleine so eine kleine schalt
wasserdichte schalt wasserdichte box an die wand machen und dort dann halt das verlängerungskabel
anschließen mit dem mit mit der ladestation also das ist nicht schwer ich gehe davon aus
es macht jeder elektriker easy in einer stunde oder so die box habe ich ja auch die habe
ich ja schon da die muss sie muss ja nicht kaufen oder so die kabel kannst du noch selbst
anschließen naja woran denn woran woran soll ich dir anschließen ich also es muss irgendjemand
im keller an den kasten gehen ein kabel legen von dem kasten an das fenster dann am fenster
vorbei in hof das geht aber das ist alles offen also da kommt man durch im hof muss
er so eine kleine wasserdichte box hinsetzen und in der box muss er dann anschließen die
die fünf kabel von der von der sobald die box da ist kann ich da selbst anschließen
ja aber unten am schaltschrank irgendwelche verlängerungs dinger legen und eventuell
noch eine sicherung einbauen und so das kann ich nicht oder sagen wir mal so ich könnte
das wahrscheinlich schon aber erstens traue ich mich das nicht und zweitens muss das ja
eh jemand machen der ahnung davon hat ich brauche keinen eigenen zähler ich habe doch
in der in meiner ladestation steht doch drinne in meiner wallbox steht doch drinne wie viel
er verbraucht ach es gibt extra strom tarife zum auto aufladen oder was oder wie schickt
mal link blitz zeig mal zeig mal schickt mal nach was muss ich gucken also das heißt man
braucht einen eigenen zähler ja aber wie eigener zähler das muss doch dann irgendeiner sein
der von von dem von dem netzbetreiber wieder geeicht und und autorisiert und was auch immer
ist okay zeig mal ja eh auto zu hause ökologisch laden gut ich meine das funktioniert mit jeder
wallbox das muss ja keine spezielle sein das ist ja die wollen wahrscheinlich ihre eigenen
sachen kaufen aber das ist natürlich blödsinn das geht natürlich mit jedem
der muss nicht buddeln der kann einfach das durch durch durch leere rohr schieben ich
habe ein leerrohr vom keller durch die wand in hof also der muss eigentlich nur das kabel
anschließen ok ok das wäre natürlich wirklich sehr nice so was da muss ich mal schlaum machen
ja und wie wo muss der zähler dann hin ich meine der muss ja wahrscheinlich hinter nee
ok ich habe echt keine ahnung wie das wie das wie das funken soll ja ein verteiler dürfte
die zähler sind jetzt nicht mehr so groß ich habe aber keine ahnung wie das dann funktioniert
also das ist dann ein zweiter zähler der kommt dann quasi parallel zum jetzigen zähler von
den stadtwerken oder wie das dann quasi auf dem stadtwerke zähler das drauf ist was ich
im haus verbrauchen auf dem anderen das drauf ist was ich im auto verbrauche oder wie oder
was oder wo ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktionieren soll aber ok muss ich mal muss
ich mal gucken doch das wäre besser aber ich habe keine solar panels auf dem dach zur
zeit also das werde ich mir nächstes jahr erst angucken so lange irgendwie muss ich
gerade aufladen ja super
ja da muss ich mal gucken was es da was es da gibt ja
ja leute alles klar ich glaube das reicht für heute wir machen das nächste mal weiter
aber schon mal pock dass das mit dem login funktioniert hat muss ich sagen sehr nice
jetzt ist betke angesagt bis denn macht es gut zu ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen bis
denn